Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 255. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich spreche in Mikrophone und werde versuchen, dieses Chaos Radio irgendwie ein bisschen zusammenzuhalten. Was kompliziert wird, weil we put the chaos back into the Chaos Communication Congress, weil der ist ja unfassbar gut organisiert dieses Jahr. Ich habe für das Ticket einlösend irgendwie weniger als zehn Minuten angestanden. Es gab keine Schlange, wenn man, als ich mein Decktelefon registrieren wollte. Das wird heute hier ein bisschen anders. Wir haben es wie immer gemacht auf dem Chaos Communication Congress, nämlich uns ein paar Sachen rausgesucht, wo wir dachten, wollen wir mal gerne darüber sprechen, weil das klingt ganz interessant. Das hat aber dieses Jahr so funktioniert, dass ich schon Dinge gesehen habe, das aber nicht die Dinge sind, über die wir heute sprechen. Das heißt, ich versuche ja immer für Hörerinnen und Hörer am Start zu sein und das Unwissen in Wissen zu verwandeln. Das passiert tatsächlich heute bei mir auch live. Herzlich willkommen auch dazu. Und ganz am Ende der Sendung, das kann ich schon mal ankündigen, werde ich etwas über die Zukunftspläne des Chaosradios sagen. Da könnt ihr schon mal sehr, sehr gespannt sein. So, die erste Gästin heute ist Anne Roth. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Du bist Referentin für Netzpolitik bei den Linken. Im Bundestag und Netzaktivistin, Stammgästin beim Chaosradio. Du musst immer was sagen, weil wenn du es siehst, das kann man im Radio überhaupt gar nicht. Sehr gut, alles. Und du hattest keinen Talk beim Kongress. Das ist nicht unwichtig, weil alle Themen, die wir heute machen, sind nicht nur inhaltlich von Interesse, sondern zeigen auch so ein bisschen, wie der Chaos-Kongress funktioniert, abseits der großen Dinge, die man überall lesen kann. Also es gibt ja zum Chaos-Kongress immer auch die großen Sachen, die passieren. Also das ist dieses Jahr die Gesundheitsakte, die möglicherweise nicht ganz so sicher ist, wie sich das bestimmte Leute gedacht haben. Und dann gab es diese Geschichte mit Finspy und Finfisher. Also da hat anscheinend eine, anscheinend sollen deutsche Programmierer an Überwachungssoftware mitgearbeitet haben, was eigentlich so hätte gar nicht geschehen dürfen. Und dann gibt es diese Tracks auf dem Chaos Communication Congress, wo wichtige Menschen wichtige Dinge sagen. Und dann gibt es aber auch Themen, die passieren einfach so. Dein Thema war auch so eins.
Das stimmt. Das ist das Thema, was ich letztes Jahr mit einem Talk tatsächlich schon besprochen habe und deswegen dachte ich, ich muss jetzt dieses Jahr nicht nochmal mich in die große Gruppe derer drängen, die versuchen durch das kleine Nadelöhr der akzeptierten Talks zu kommen. Also ich hab das nicht nochmal eingereicht und hab auch gar nicht weiter drüber nachgedacht, sondern dachte, ey, ein Glück Weihnachten und endlich ist Schluss. Jetzt kommt nur noch der Kongress. Ich lehne mich zurück und irgendwie genieße das hier und mache mir keine Arbeit. Und das klingt jetzt, glaube ich, vielleicht gekünsteter als es war. Aber es war tatsächlich so, dass ich dann hier ankam und dachte, hm, aber vielleicht gibt es ja Leute, die wollen auch gerne über dieses Thema reden, über das ich letztes Jahr und auch beim Camping Talk gehabt habe. Und eigentlich würde ich die auch gerne finden. Und dann fragte mich auch jemand, machst du eigentlich noch einen Talk? Und ich so Nö. Aber wir könnten ja mal drüber reden. Ich gucke einfach, dass ich einen Self Organized Sessions Slot finde und melde das an. Und vielleicht kommt ja irgendwer. Und genau das haben wir dann gemacht.
Aber das finde ich sozusagen wirklich das Spannende an diesem Konzept Chaos Communication Congress, dass es halt Säle gibt, wo hunderte von Leuten reinpassen, man aber auch die Gelegenheit hat, sich sowas zu organisieren und dann auch etwas dafür findet. Sache erst mal, was ist das Thema?
Das Thema ist digitale Gewalt gegen Frauen.
So, du hast da jetzt schon Talks drüber gehalten. Kannst du ganz kurz den aktuellen Stand geben? Und warum das für dich also was das Thema umfasst und warum das für dich ein Thema ist?
Ich versuche das ganz kurz. Digitale Gewalt gegen Frauen ist ein Überbegriff oder ein Dachbegriff für verschiedene Formen von Aggressionen, die im digitalen Raum stattfinden oder mittels technischer Geräte oder vermittels Software, also über das Smartphone per App, in Chats, aber auch auf sozialen Plattformen. Und da ist die viel besprochene Hate Speech natürlich mit dabei. Das ist gewissermaßen die Spitze des Eisbergs, des Problems. Und dann gibt es aber noch ganz viel anderes, was mit dazugehört, was mehr oder weniger öffentlich stattfindet. Und ich konzentriere mich mehr auf den Bereich, über den wenig gesprochen wird und der auch nicht so gut sichtbar ist. Und zwar die digitale Gewalt im Bereich der Partnerschaftsgewalt, auch genannt häusliche Gewalt. Das heißt, das fängt an mit Stalking, mit Überwachungssoftware, mit sogenanntem Stalkerware findet mittlerweile auch per Internet of Things statt. Hat aber eben viel zu tun mit Kontrolle und Bedrohung, auch in gewesenen Partnerschaften beispielsweise. Also, dass sich Smartphones gut eignen, dazu andere Leute zu lokalisieren, muss sich hier niemandem erklären. Dass aber eben auch geteilte Passwörter dazu genutzt werden können, Mail-Accounts zu überwachen, alle anderen Accounts zu überwachen, sich Zugang zu verschaffen, auch zu Rechnern, Webcams zu aktivieren, Mikrofone zu installieren, das alles auszunutzen, um zu überwachen und zu kontrollieren. Das ist so ein bisschen ein kleiner Einblick in eine sehr unangenehme Welt, die sehr viel ausgenutzt wird, weil sich digitale Technologien eben eignen, zum Manipulieren und Kontrollieren. Und darum dreht sich dieses Thema.
Was mich dabei immer wieder überrascht ist, ich finde, da ist ganz viel drin, was sowieso ein Problem ist. Also zum Beispiel, dass man Passwörter jetzt eigentlich nicht teilt. Und wenn man das doch macht, das Problem geht, dass es ein Problem ist, es existiert sozusagen in der größeren Welt. Und das kann dann bei dem bestimmten Thema, spielt das dann auch eine Rolle. Genauso Internet of Things. Da haben viele Leute mittlerweile, da macht man sich zu wenig Gedanken drüber, wie das eigentlich funktionieren kann und sicher sein kann. Auch das kann dann ausgenutzt werden. Aber der eine Punkt, dem ihr eigentlich nur hier begegnet, ist diese Überwachungssoftware, also diese Stalkerware für Smartphones. Haben die überhaupt noch einen anderen Sinn?
Diese Software, ja, das ist eine klassische Dual-Use-Software.
Das ist genau der Punkt, den ich mich frage. Was ist der andere Nutzen?
Der andere Nutzen, würde ich sagen, hat das eigentlich keinen. Da gibt es zwei, mindestens, Eltern, die ihre Kinder überwachen. Ich kenne auch gerade in diesem Kontext hier nicht wenige Leute, die mir erklären, dass sie das ganz dringend brauchen, weil sie ja sonst ihre Kinder gar nicht alleine rumlaufen lassen könnten, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen oder nicht so früh oder nicht so weit oder irgendwie sowas in dieser Art.
Ich möchte kurz eine Handbewegung, die ich an meine Stirn mache, kommentieren, weil es ja hier Radio ist im weitesten Sinne.
Ja, ich teile das vollständig.
Aber das ist interessant, weil ich würde das gar nicht als in anderen Nutzen sehen, sondern das ist ja sozusagen auch das Überwachen von Menschen, die das eigentlich nicht verdient haben und was man eigentlich auch gar nicht darf.
Gute Frage, strittig.
Ich will gerade ein anderes Thema, vielleicht sollten wir mal... Es gibt ja eine Kinderrechtskonvention, die ja auch in Deutschland umgesetzt... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das überhaupt noch darf bei Kindern, aber okay.
Aber die Eltern glauben auf jeden Fall, dass sie das dürfen, die meisten Kinder glauben es auf jeden Fall auch.
Für Kinder ist immer erstmal alles normal.
Genau, die wachsen dann damit auf. Aber das ist wirklich nochmal so ein echt schönes Thema, dieses Eltern überwachen ihre Kinder und warum ist das schlecht? Und dann gibt es ja auch Arbeitgeber und Arbeitgeberinnen, die ihre Angestellten überwachen aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Also wir alle kennen das, du rufst im Callcenter an und vorher kommt eine automatische Stimme aus. Und in den Gründen zeichnen wir dieses Gespräch auf. Und wenn sie das nicht wollen, dann müssen sie jetzt sagen, nein, ich möchte das nicht. Und dazu gibt es sozusagen noch verschiedene andere Facetten. Damit kenne ich mich nicht so gut aus, aber ich weiß, dass solche Software in dem Kontext auch benutzt wird.
Aber da freut mich so, technisch ist es dieselbe Software, aber der Markt ist doch. Es gibt doch also Software, die wird für Kinder vermarktet. Also hier machen sie das und das für ihre Kinder. Und für die Stalkerware gibt es auch einen eigenen?
Für Stalkerware gibt es auf jeden Fall einen eigenen Markt. Die Software für den Eltern-Kind-Kontext ist zum Teil dieselbe, die aber auch dann vermarktet wird für Partnerschaftsüberwachung. Und zwar exakt dieselbe App mit sozusagen unterschiedlichen Webseiten, die das dann mehr oder weniger leicht findbar machen, die sich aber ganz leicht googeln lassen.
Also exakt dieselbe App oder technisch dieselbe App mit einer anderen Verpackung?
Also ich habe das persönlich nicht recherchiert. Das heißt, ich weiß, das sind dieselben Apps. Ob die exakt gleich verpackt werden, kann ich dir nicht sagen. Das weiß ich nicht, aber ich weiß, dass das dieselbe Software ist zum Teil. Okay, so. Und in dem Kontext möchte ich gerne noch mal erwähnen, auch für alle, die jetzt hier gerade zuhören, das ist nicht erlaubt. Also Hacker Paragraph, Zugriff auf anderer Leute Geräte, ohne dass die Bescheid wissen, ist nicht in Ordnung aus verschiedenen Gründen und im Übrigen auch verboten.
Nur, dass ihr Bescheid wisst. Was war der Stand nach deinen Talks? Also wenn du dazu Talks machst, heißt das, du hast ein Interesse daran, darüber zu informieren, aufzuklären, Mitschreiter zu finden, Mitschreiterinnen.
Ja, genau all das.
Was war der Stand nach dem Camp, kann man ja sagen. Also du hast letztes Jahr auf dem Kongressentalk, jetzt auf dem Camp.
Was war danach der Stand? Dass in beiden Fällen ich eine Menge positives Feedback gekriegt habe, dass von Leuten, also immer wieder auch und auch hier jetzt nach dem Workshop im Übrigen, wieder Leute, die sagen, ja ich hab gehört, dass du darüber redest, jetzt habe ich mir angehört, was du sagst. Ich bin total geschockt, wie krass das ist, wie oft das vorkommt und dass da keiner darüber spricht.
Wie oft kommt das vor?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, weil es tatsächlich...
Moment, du hast gerade gesagt, Leute sagen, wie krass...
Ich muss mich aussprechen lassen. Es gibt dazu keine Studien, es gibt dazu keine Forschung, jedenfalls nicht im deutschsprachigen Raum. Was ich aber tue, ist, ich rede sehr viel mit Frauenberatungsstellen, mit dem Dachverband der Frauenberatungsstellen, mit Leuten in Frauenhäusern. Und da gibt es auch Umfragen. Die sind nicht repräsentativ empirisch bis sonst wohin. Aber es gibt Umfragen, wo sich draus erkennen lässt, wo die Beraterinnen in den Frauenhäusern und Frauenberatungsstellen sagen, in der Mehrzahl der Fälle, wo Frauen zu uns kommen mit Gewalterfahrung, auch körperlichen Gewalterfahrung, aber nicht nur, also was auch immer dann der Beratungsfall ist, spielt digitale Gewalt eine Rolle und Stalker-Aware auf Mobiltelefonen ist ein Problem, mit dem wir ständig zu tun haben und mit dem wir nicht fertig werden. Das ist ja dann die andere Seite. Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich bei Chaos-Events darüber rede, dass denen die technische Expertise fehlt. Und noch mal zurück zu der Frage, wie oft kommt das vor? Lässt sich nicht spezifizieren, aber die sagen, das passiert ihnen häufig in der Mehrzahl der Fälle und ansteigend und das ist auch international zu beobachten.
Also die Vermutung ist auf jeden Fall gerechtfertigt, das ist nicht kein Problem. Und ist das, also ich mein, es ist so ein bisschen immer so preaching to the choir, also man sitzt, man ist auf einem Chaos-Congress, Datensouveränität ist mehr oder weniger Konsens. Natürlich sagen dann alle, die in den Vortrag kommen, das ist ja finster und wir wussten es nur noch nicht, aber man muss wahrscheinlich nicht Überzeugungsarbeit leisten, dass es sozusagen schlimm ist, also im Gegensatz zu Eltern, die ihre Kinder überwachen. Glaubst du, das ist gesellschaftlich auch so? Also weil dieses, was mich an digitaler Perchenhaftigkeit manchmal total überrascht, ist dieses so, sich gegenseitig die Passwörter zum E-Mailfach geben, ist ein Zeichen des Vertrauens.
Das ist glaube ich ein riesiges Problem, auch weit unterhalb der Schwelle zur digitalen Gewalt, wo bei Jugendlichen fängt das an und das hört bei älteren Leuten aber noch lange nicht auf, eben dieses scheinbare Zeichen des Vertrauens und gekoppelt mit dem Problem, das in der Regel in einer Lebensgemeinschaft, wie auch immer die gestaltet ist, häufig eine Person sozusagen, die ist mit dem technischen Wissen, die früher den Videorecorder konfiguriert hat und inzwischen die gesamte IT-Landschaft managt und natürlich in der Regel auch Zugänge hat, von denen die anderen entweder gar nichts wissen oder aber ganz froh sind, dass die die hat, weil sie selber keinen Bock haben, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Genau, das wollte ich fragen, glaubst du, dass es in der breiteren Schicht der Gesellschaft, also ich sage mal nicht KongressbesucherInnen tatsächlich als auch was Gutes angesehen wird, so eine Software auf dem Handy zu haben, weil dann kann der andere ja schnell helfen?
Das ist mir noch nicht begegnet. Im Unterschied dazu ist es so, dass viel von dem Feedback, was bei mir ankommt oder wenn ich Leute konkret frage, also auch gerade in einem Chaos-Umfeld, Netz-Community, ist dir das schon mal begegnet? Kennst du das aus meinem Umfeld, dass häufig Leute sagen, ja mich hat auch schon mal jemand gefragt, ja ich habe auch eine Freundin, die hat mir davon erzählt, das kommt bei mir relativ viel an. Und das ist ja auch nicht so überraschend, wenn man sich die Zahlen von häuslicher Gewalt anguckt. Das ist ja auch ein großes Problem. Dann ist natürlich logisch, dass diese digitalen Aspekte davon auch nicht selten sind.
Und was macht man dagegen? Oder kann man was dagegen machen? Also die eine Sache, die ich mich immer frage, und das ist die Frage nach einem ganz konkreten praktischen Tipp, kann ich überhaupt erkennen, dass sowas auf meinem Handy ist? Gibt es da eine Vorgehensweise Leitfaden?
Nein, das gibt es in der Regel nicht. Es gibt kaum Leute, die sich überhaupt damit beschäftigen. Da gibt es jetzt ein Forschungsprojekt, zum Beispiel, die versuchen, Frauenberatungsstellen, das ist in New York, damit zur Seite zu stehen. Stalkerware ist ja aber auch nur ein Aspekt dieses ganzen Problems. Das ist sozusagen der absolute harte Fall. Das ist nicht selten, aber das ist bei weitem nicht alles. Also dieses Zugreifen auf Mail-Accounts, Mitlesen von Chats, gegebenenfalls einfach weil die Passwörter vorhanden sind. Dazu brauche ich ja keine Stalkerware. Das kann ich ja gegebenenfalls auch irgendwie anders machen. Das gibt sozusagen eine ganze Facette von allen möglichen Problemen.
Ich hänge mich gerade an der Stalkerware aus zwei Punkten auf. Das eine ist, weil der Themenkomplex ist so riesig. Das ist sozusagen eins, da kann man gerade drüber reden. Und das andere finde ich, das ist auch was Besonderes im Sinne von, für das Tauschen des Mail-Passworts gibt es zumindest im Prinzip die einfache Lösung, ich setze das Passwort zurück. Also klar, auch da gibt es wieder, musst du können, musst du wissen, wie es geht, es muss als Konzept verfügbar sein, aber theoretisch ist sozusagen, gibt es dann eine eindeutige Klärungsweise. Und das andere, auch wenn das jetzt ein bisschen zynisch klingt, sozusagen Hate Speech ist ganz klar als solche erkennbar. Also wenn du runtergemacht wirst, durch über digitale Kommunikationskanäle, dann passiert das ganz deutlich. Und ich finde die Stalker aber deswegen so spannend, weil das perfide daran ist, dass es halt geheim ist.
Also heimliche Kameras in der Wohnung und Mikros irgendwo und das ist auch alles heimlich.
Klar, das ist auch, aber im Gegensatz zu Hate Speech und zu ich kontrolliere deine digitale Infrastruktur, du weißt es aber. Das ist dieser Bereich von ich mache Dinge, von denen du gar nichts weißt und möglicherweise sogar gar nichts wissen kannst. Und das hat ja dann auch so, es gibt diesen Begriff Gaslighting, also jemanden unterstellen, dass er sich nur Dinge einbildet. Und das ist ja was, das kann man gar nicht erkennen. Und deswegen finde ich das sozusagen einen spannenden Aspekt in diesem ganzen Thema.
Die Frage war ja dann auch, was kann man da eigentlich machen? Und ich glaube, es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Ebenen des etwas Machens. Das fängt an bei, weiß ich nicht, einer riesigen Kampagne, die da heißt, teile deine Passwörter nicht. Genauso wie du dein Tagebuch in deinem in die Hand drückst, gib deine Passwörter nicht weiter. Klingt total banal, aber gehört zur Medienbildung von Jugendlichen bis Erwachsenen dazu. Und das fehlt im Moment, finde ich noch ganz deutlich. Bis hin zu vielleicht mal der Fragestellung, wieso ist es eigentlich legal, dass diese Software verkauft wird, bis hin zu vielleicht einer Kampagne, die sich an Viren Software Hersteller richtet. Das gibt es teilweise auch schon. Warum wird das eigentlich nicht als Malware erkannt, wenn so eine Software unerkannt auf einem Mobilgerät ist, die ich da gar nicht haben will, gegebenenfalls?
Ich muss von ganz dores fragen, gibt es schon Virenprogramme für Smartphones?
Also offenbar, ja, ich weiß, doch, doch, auf jeden Fall. Also es gibt mittlerweile auch Anfänge von Studien, die sich damit befassen, welche Viren Software inzwischen sowas auch erkennen können. Und ich glaube, wir brauchen vor allen Dingen aber auch eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion über dieses Thema, weil das so im Verborgenen stattfindet und so wenig überhaupt thematisiert wird. Und deswegen halte ich ja diese Vorträge, um zu sagen, wir haben hier ein Problem. Das gibt es nicht erst seit gestern. Und wenn wir über Cybercrime reden, dann können wir nicht nur über Verbrechen im digitalen Raum reden, die sich gegen Unternehmen und Netz richten, sondern wir müssen auch diese Seite von strafbarem Verhalten gegen Personen gerichtet mal anerkennen als Problem, mit dem sich diese Gesellschaft beschäftigen muss.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, das ist ja eh verboten, heißt das, eigentlich müssten die gerade bestehenden Rechtsmittel reichen, um dagegen vorzugehen?
Würde ich sagen.
Das heißt, die Bundesregierung muss keine Worte haben. Wie würde er in der Bundesregierung... Nee, ich überlege gerade...
Also die man auch kritisieren sollte.
Es gibt ja diese Namensgebung jetzt für neue Gesetze. Ich überlege gerade, wie ein auf dieses Problem abgestelltes Gesetz, wahrscheinlich gute Beziehung gesetzt. Wird dann sowas gearbeitet?
Also alle Fragen, die ich im Rahmen meines Jobs um die Ecke über Abgeordnete an die Bundesregierung habe richten lassen. Auch zum Beispiel in Richtung BSI. Ob sich das BSI, das ja zwar einerseits im Kontext Unternehmen und Netze und Infrastrukturen arbeitet, aber auch diese Abteilung BSI für Bürger hat. Und die Frage, fühlen die sich auch zuständig für dieses Problem? Da sagt die Bundesregierung ja vor einem Jahr, hat sie das gesagt. Nein, das ist nicht unser Problem.
Wessen sonst?
Gute Frage, also dieses Problem der digitalen Gewalt gegen Frauen, das ist sozusagen eine winzig kleine Schnittmenge von zwei sehr unterschiedlichen Zuständigkeitsbereichen, nämlich so Frauenkram, Gewalt gegen Frauen, Frauenministerium und IT-Problematiken irgendwie so zwischen BMI und BMJ und manchmal auch im Wirtschaftsministerium noch angesiedelt. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel, und das hab ich auch schon gemacht, es gibt ja jetzt in einzelnen Bundesländern inzwischen Staatsanwaltschaften für Cybercrime. Und es gibt in einem Bundesland, in Nordrhein-Westfalen, auch eine, die ist spezifisch für Hate Speech zuständig. Wenn man die fragt, sind sie zuständig, also ich hab konkret einen von den Cyberanwälten aus Bayern mal gefragt, sind sie eigentlich auch zuständig für Fälle von digitaler Gewalt im häuslichen Bereich? Dann sagt er, nein, das machen die Kollegen aus den Sexualstrafrechtsdezernaten. Und die haben natürlich aber von den digitalen Themen. Also nicht natürlich nicht, aber das wird jetzt hier niemanden überraschend zu hören, dass wenn du mit irgendwelchen Internetsachen zur Polizei oder zur Staatsanwaltschaft gehst und sagst, hier, ich hab hier ein Problem als Person, dass die in der Regel damit nicht gut umgehen können. Und das ist in dem Bereich auch so. Es gibt also keine Zuständigkeiten, die beide Themen gemeinsam tatsächlich vernünftig abdecken können.
Aber das ist eigentlich total absurd, weil eigentlich ist es doch, wenn die, ich sag mal, die IT-Zuständigen ihren Job ordentlich machen würden, würde sich der Rest des Problems doch von selbst erliegen?
Ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also ich glaube so ganz von selber nicht. Aber ich glaube, es wäre ein großer Schritt vorwärts gemacht, wenn es tatsächlich mal definiert würde als Problem, das in dieser Gesellschaft existiert, das gelöst werden muss. Und das natürlich auch gegebenenfalls strafrechtlich aufgearbeitet werden muss. Ich bin jetzt als Linke auch keine wirklich große Freundin von mehr Gesetze und härtre Gesetze und mehr Polizei und so. Ich finde aber schon, dass es irgendeine Form von Zuständigkeit geben muss, wenn Frauen von sowas betroffen sind, wie sie sich dagegen wehren können.
Ich finde das total irre. Also zu sagen, dass es bei so einem Thema Leute gibt, die sagen, da sind wir nicht viel zuständig, obwohl es, wenn wir jetzt hier auf der Bühne sitzen, darüber reden relativ klar scheint, dass man sich eigentlich mit dem Thema beschäftigen müsste. Na gut, jetzt hast du, um noch mal kurz sozusagen auf die Kongressegnen zu gehen, jetzt hast du gedacht, naja, vielleicht interessiert es ja doch jemanden. Nur für den Fall, dass jetzt jemand zuhört und beim nächsten Kongress denkt, Mensch, das hätte ich auch gerne gewusst. Wie organisiert man eine selbstorganisierte Session?
Ich glaube, ein guter Anfang ist rauszukriegen, ob sich außer mir noch irgendjemand für das Thema interessiert. Erstmal so im Vorfeld so ein bisschen. Also ich persönlich habe einfach die Frage in Twitter geworfen und gefragt, gäbe es noch Leute, die vielleicht Interesse hätten, über das Thema zu reden, wenn da so ein bisschen was zurückkommt. Das ist ein gutes Indiz.
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen, das soll jetzt nicht zum Prozent sein, wie viele Follower hast du?
Einige.
Fünfstellig? Also das heißt sozusagen, du hast da einen großen Resonanzraum.
Ich hab da einen Resonanzraum, genau das funktioniert.
Wenn jetzt sozusagen jemand da ist, der denkt so, also Thema hab ich schon, aber nicht sozusagen von ganz alleine zum großen Resonanzraum, hättest du da Tipps, wo man hingehen können, an welche Stellen, um sozusagen sein Thema abzulegen und zu fragen, hat vielleicht jemand Bock?
Ich kann das natürlich auch machen, ohne vorher mir dieses Feedback einzusammeln. Und wenn ich Twitter und ein paar Hashtags benutze, glaube ich, dann funktioniert das auch für kleinere Accounts darüber, ein bisschen Feedback zu bekommen mit dem entsprechenden Thema, mit dem ich da was mache. Ansonsten kann ich ja auch einfach gucken, welche anderen Gruppen sind vielleicht thematisch ein bisschen verwandt und gibt es da vielleicht Leute, die da sich spezifisch ver interessieren. Und was ich dann machen kann, also mit oder ohne Feedback, ist mir im Wiki zum Congress ein Account klicken und dann da auf, das ist glaube ich direkt schon in der Eingangsseite vom Wiki, gibt es den Link Self Organized Sessions. Und was ich auch tun muss, ist in den Fahrplan gucken und gucken, wo sind noch Slots frei. Also ich muss ja gewissermaßen einen Raum finden, also idealerweise einen, der im Fahrplan irgendwo vorkommt, weil sonst ist es ganz schwer, auch Leute dazu zu bewegen, da hinzukommen, wenn das nicht im Fahrplan steht. Das heißt ich gucke erstmal im Fahrplan, wo ist noch was frei? Und das war auch in meinem Fall, das war jetzt sehr spät, nicht mehr so ganz einfach, also ich hab dann einen ganz kleinen Raum gefunden, wo noch 40 Minuten drinne waren. Und eigentlich war das eine Stunde und bis es mir dann gelungen war, meinen Wiki-Account zu klicken und bestätigt zu kriegen und so weiter, waren nur noch 40 Minuten über von der Stunde. Empfiehlt sich nicht, das irgendwie so spät zu machen, eigentlich ist es schon klüger, das ein bisschen früher zu machen. Genau und dann trägst du halt in dem Formular für neue Session, Titel, Beschreibung, Ort und Zeit ein und klickst auf Speichern und dann steht das im Fahrplan.
Und das lesen auch, also so wichtig sind ja mal, da kann man ja gut Dinge reinschreiben, aber das liest denn auch jemand?
Also in meinem Fall haben das eine Menge Leute gelesen und es sind auch ein paar gekommen.
Wie viel?
40 ungefähr, ja.
Okay und was habt ihr dann gemacht? Du wolltest ja explizit keinen Talk halten, dann sitzt man dann im Raum und dann sagt man so, Hi, digitale Gewalt gegen Frauen.
Ich hab das ja schon in die Beschreibung reingeschrieben, dass das kein Talk ist. Nichtsdestotrotz sind dann in dem Moment 5 Leute aufgestanden und gesagt, ach, das ist kein Talk, dann geh ich jetzt wieder. Das ist aber, ich mein, völlig okay. Das ist halt so auf dem Kopf. Ich bin echt froh über alle, die kommen und sich für das Thema interessieren. Und im Grunde haben wir dann nichts anderes gemacht als eine ganz, ganz kurze Vorstellungsrunde. Das hat geklappt. Also wenn man die wirklich sagt, so ein Stichwort, warum bist du hier, einmal ringsrum, um so ein bisschen Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, wollen die jetzt nur zuhören, wollen die was machen, was wollen die gerne machen? Und was ich mir vorher überlegt hatte, war zu sagen, okay, ich finde es super, dass ihr euch für das Thema interessiert. Ich habe ein paar Ideen, in welche Richtung es gehen könnte. Die sind auch wirklich sehr, sehr unterschiedlich gewesen. Nämlich, was ich mir vorstellen kann und finde, was dringend fehlt, ist irgendeine Form von Kampagne gegen Snorkelware hierzulande. Wer will sich mit sowas beschäftigen? Man könnte da zum Beispiel mal die Zahlungsdienstleister so ein bisschen ins Visier nehmen und sagen, wieso ermöglicht ihr eigentlich, dass sowas verkauft wird? Findet ihr das mit euren ethischen Prinzipien vereinbar? Ich finde nicht. Könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass sowas stattfindet. Oder einfach mal eine Aufklärungskampagne zu Snorkelware. Eine zweite Idee war ganz konkrete technische Unterstützung für Frauenberatungsstellen. Die ist nämlich dringend nötig, weil die ganzen Beratungsstellen und Frauenhäuser, die haben zwar dieses Problem und werden von den betroffenen Frauen dazu gefragt. Die haben aber weder die Zeit noch das Geld, sich dazu selber zu befähigen, damit umzugehen. Die brauchen ganz dringend Unterstützung von Leuten, die versuchen, bestimmte technische Fragen zu beantworten. Und ich denke, die meisten im Raum und die jetzt gerade zuhören, wissen, dass technisches Wissen keine statische Angelegenheit ist. Das habe ich einmal und dann kann ich die nächsten fünf Jahre damit arbeiten, sondern ich muss im Grunde permanent mein eigenes Wissen aktualisieren. Und das kann niemand nebenbei machen. Und deswegen ist es dringend nötig, dass irgendeine Form von Struktur, Infozentrum, Gruppe, Netzwerk oder so sich bildet, um diesen Frauenberatungsstellen zu helfen. Denn die Bundesregierung tut es nicht, dezidiert nicht. Da ist quasi kein Geld für vorhanden. Das war sozusagen eine zweite Idee und eine dritte Idee, mal zu sagen, jetzt gibt es im Moment einen Gesetzentwurf zum Thema Hasskriminalität. Der berührt auch das Thema digitale Gewalt, nicht Stalkerware, aber andere Teile davon. Aber aus verschiedenen Gründen ist dieser Gesetzentwurf echt schlecht, weil der vor allen Dingen ganz viel mit Überwachung und Weitergabe von IP-Adressen und Passwörtern und so zu tun hat. Und vielleicht müssen wir uns damit auch mal beschäftigen, einerseits aus einer klassischen, würde ich sagen, Congress-Perspektive zu sagen, da kommt schon wieder so ein Überwachungsgesetz und wie werden wir das jetzt wieder los? Aber zweitens natürlich auch aus der Perspektive. Wir haben hier ein Problem, das ist, finde ich, eigentlich ein Kernthema dieser Community hier. Und jetzt kommt die Bundesregierung und was macht sie? Sie wirft ein neues Überwachungsgesetz auf das ganze Ding drauf. Aber es ist schon auch an uns, uns eine bessere Lösung auszudenken, bevor die mit noch mehr Überwachungsmaßnahmen kommen. Denn das kann die Lösung nicht sein. Und die werden sich diese Lösung nicht ausdenken. Und dazu muss man sich auch mit dem Thema beschäftigen. Das waren so die drei kleinen Grübchen, die wir da hatten.
Jetzt sind ja 40 Minuten echt nicht viel. Was ist denn der Status jetzt, nachdem es vorbei ist? Ist das eine offene Mailing-Liste?
Das ist sie bisher. Also bisher ist es wirklich 40 Minuten. Dann noch 30 Leute. Es gibt im Moment nur den Stand, es gibt eine Mailing-Liste, weil die Leute, die da waren, sich weiter vernetzen. Wie das sein wird, ob das dann offen sein wird, oder ob es irgendwas Öffenes dazu gibt, das werden wir nach diesem Kongress besprechen.
Das wird die Frage anstellen. Ich höre jetzt das Chaosradio oder habe mitbekommen, es gab diese Session und habe gedacht, da wäre ich auch gerne gewesen, dir respektiere ich mich für das Thema.
Schreibt mir. Ja. Wie? Entweder ich bin per Twitter ganz gut zu erreichen.
Du heißt da?
Analyst, A-N-N-A-L-I-S-T. Genauso heißt auch mein Mail-Account, analystatariseup.net, da kann man mir auch hinschreiben. Ansonsten benutze ich jeden denkbaren Messenger außer WhatsApp. Aber es gibt sozusagen viele Möglichkeiten, mich zu erreichen. Und ich glaube, der ersten Kontakt lässt sich schon irgendwie hinkriegen. Und Leute, die tatsächlich ernsthaft Interesse haben, irgendwas in dem breiten Spektrum der Möglichkeiten, die es da im Moment gibt, zu tun, können sich sehr gerne an mich wenden. Ich komme auch in halte Vorträge darüber.
Okay. Letzte Frage. Weil das ja gerade mit so Digitalthemen und Digitalüberwachungsthemen häufiger der Fall ist. Wie hält man solche Themen, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sagen soll, sexy? Das sind ja Dinge, da benennt man mal das Problem. Und wenn man das zum ersten Mal macht, gibt es auch auf einem Kongress ein großes Hallo dann. Aber die gehen ja meistens leider nicht weg, sondern sind einfach immer weiter da.
Also Journalisten wollen immer gerne tolle Opferfälle. Die habe ich nicht. Beziehungsweise die gibt es natürlich, aber aus gut vermittelbaren Gründen sind die Betroffenen nicht wirklich begeistert davon, sich jetzt vorne auf die Bühne zu setzen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass einfach die Bearbeitung von einzelnen Aspekten, von diesem Thema, die ja alle auch noch mal einzeln sozusagen rausgegriffen werden können, ich glaube, wenn wir anfangen, uns ein bisschen intensiver mit dieser Stalkerware-Problematik zu beschäftigen, dass man da auch noch mal interessante, so ein bisschen saftigere Geschichten draus machen kann. Einfach in der Beschreibung dessen, wie funktioniert das, was ist das, wer sind die Leute dahinter, wer benutzt das und so. Und dann gibt es noch, ja, alleine der Bereich Internet of Things, den wir jetzt nicht weiter besprochen haben. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein Thema für diesen Kongress. Das ist auch ein IT-Sicherheitsthema. Warum haben diese ganzen Scheiß-Alexas und so weiter haufenweise Zugänge für verschiedene Leute, die aber nicht voneinander abgrenzbar sind, sodass eine Person, die das benutzt, wenn sie es administriert sehen kann, was alle anderen da machen. Wieso ist das überhaupt so und nicht anders gelöst? Da finde ich sehr viel Verwandtschaft zu Kongresthemen, wo wir noch viel von haben werden.
Also quasi das große Thema nicht aus den Augen verlieren, aber immer die gut zu erzählende Anekdote auch nicht vergessen.
Das gilt, glaube ich, immer.
Kann man auch mal sagen. Sehr schön. Anne Roth, ihr wisst, wie ihr sie erreichen könnt. Vielen Dank, dass du hier warst.
Gerne. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Dankeschön. So, dann würde ich die Leute vom Fahrrad-Sharing-System auf die Bühne bitten. Gerade waren es noch zwei. Da fehlt doch einer. So, kommen Sie zu mir. Wir wechseln hier nahtlos auf der Bühne. Ganz ohne Musik. Wir machen das Chaosradio in der Version spartanisch. Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo.
Du bist der?
Maxi.
Du bist der Maxi. Hallo, Maxi. Du bist vom... Wovon eigentlich?
Eigentlich aus dem Verschwörhaus. Und hänge jetzt auf dem Kongress in der Wikipacker-WG rum.
In der was?
In der Wikipacker-WG. In der was? Ein Ort, der ein Zusammenschluss aus Wikimedia, Wikipedia, der Open Knowledge Foundation mit Jugend hackt, und dem Verschwörhaus ist. Und wir tragen da ganz viel Zeug rein. Und haben letztendlich eine große WG mit Wohnzimmer, Soferlandschaft, mit Küche, mit ganz viel Essen unten im Esszimmer. Was aber lustigerweise nicht zum Essen da ist, sondern da ist eine Bühne drin. Und da halten Menschen dann auch noch mal dezentral Vorträge.
Kommen da oft Leute rein, die was essen wollen und dann feststellen, oh nein, hier wird mein Kopf gefüttert, nicht mein Magen.
Das war letztes Jahr so, das klappt dieses Jahr lustigerweise besser.
Für alle, die uns nur hören, jetzt ist gerade noch jemand auf die Bühne gekommen, hi. Du bist der? Stefan Eztika. Und kommst? Auch aus Ulm. Auch aus Ulm? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass er aus Ulm kommt. Bis jetzt weiß ich nur, dass er aus der WG Packer AG kommt. Also ja, auch aus der WG Packer, aber auch aus Ulm, genau. Okay, auch aus Ulm. Genau, ihr macht Dinge mit Fahrrädern. Auch. Warum? Weil es gut ist und weil es wichtig ist und weil es einen Teil zur Mobilitätswende beiträgt. Also, wenn man den Kongress kennt, ist das ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überraschend. Weil auf dem Kongress gibt es Roller. Leider nicht zum Scheren. Leider nicht zum Scheren. Wie sagt ihr denn auf Scher-Fahrräder? Also, Stopp, Halt. Ich komme aus Berlin, da gibt es alles mögliche Zeug zum Scheren. Also Autos, Fahrräder, Roller. Ulm ist, das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt habe, keine so richtig große Stadt. Gab es da schon Dinge zum Scheren, die ihr dann, wie heißt es so schön, zerforscht habt? Oder gab es da nichts zum Scheren und das hat euch dazu gebracht, hey, hier solltet ihr auch mal was geben? Es gab tatsächlich Dinge zum Scheren, nämlich Car2go hat das an Anfang genommen, weil da die Forschungseinrichtung quasi ist von Daimler, die da mit Car2go angefangen haben. Witzigerweise gibt es Car2go dort nicht mehr, weil Ulm zu klein ist für solche Modi. Und es gibt auch kein Bike Sharing bislang dort, weil Ulm hat topografisch so ein bisschen Probleme, weil es da viele Berge gibt. Und da sind dann ganz viele Sharing-Anbieter hingekommen, haben sich die Berge angeguckt und sind dann lachend wieder gegangen. Deswegen war das etwas problematisch. Das heißt, wenn man dort Dinge zum Sharing anbieten will, dann sollten die auch einen Elektromotor haben? Das wäre praktisch. Es gibt andere Orte, die auch Hügel haben. Also Stuttgart, das ist alles im Süden irgendwie komisch, aber Stuttgart hat auch Hügel. Da gibt es dann tatsächlich Beschäftigte von so Sharing-Anbietern, die dann irgendwie auf dem Lauf des Tages Fahrräder in Verbrennungsmotor getriebene Fahrzeuge laden und die wieder den Balk hochfahren. Was ein geiles Konzept. Teil des Problems ist und nicht... Ja, also es ist schwierig. So, wir haben also eine kleine Stadt mit Bergen, ohne Sharing-Infrastruktur. Und dann kommt ihr hin und sagt so, ja, das muss man doch mal ändern. So hat es gar nicht angefangen, da kann ich nicht mehr sagen dazu. Sondern was ist passiert?
Angefangen hat es vor zwei Jahren?
Zwei Jahren ziemlich.
Zwei Jahren, ja genau. Also das im Hinterkopf mit naja, wir würden halt trotzdem irgendwie gerne Sharing haben, war schon da. Aber was viel mehr da war, war, dass wir halt gesehen haben, was vor allem in München, in nahen Großstädten passiert ist zu der Zeit, nämlich diese massive Anzahl an chinesischen Bike-Sharing-Rädern, die da plötzlich aufgetaucht ist. Also manche kennen dieses Foto mit irgendwelche O-Bikes, die dann in München in Bäumen hängen oder halt irgendwie auf Straßen rumliegen und so weiter. Und was uns da halt interessiert hat, war nicht nur so ein, warum ist das jetzt so ein Ding, sondern halt auch wie funktioniert das eigentlich technisch. Und ist das jetzt schon Talkspoiler?
Nein, man kann das einfach sagen. Maxi wohnt im Verschwörhaus quasi und hängt da so rum. Und dann eines Abends saßen die beieinander und sind, haben einfach mal eben eine Fake-Firma gegründet. So kann man das eigentlich sagen. Also es war wichtiger, dass die Typo steht und die Visitenkarten und das Logo und so weiter. Das ist doch einfach Start-up-Kultur, oder? Genau, aber ohne die Gründungsabsicht, ein wirkliches Start-up zu machen. So kann man es eigentlich sagen. Und haben sich dann mal umgeguckt, was es dann da für Anbieter eigentlich gibt. Für Fahrrad-Sharing oder für Typografien für Start-ups.
Für Fahrrad-Sharing, weil was halt, also Bike-Sharing war zu diesem Zeitpunkt ja so ein riesig großes Ding. Also wo jede Woche irgendwie so eine Firma aus dem Boden aufgeploppt ist. Und das war halt so eine Art Goldgräberstimmung. Und was halt immer passiert bei so Goldgräberstimmungen, ist, dass so plötzlich Leute hast, die dir liebend gerne Schaufeln verkaufen. Und genau das ist halt auch passiert, nämlich dass man auf Alibaba, so einer chinesischen Großhandelsplattform, plötzlich komplett fertige Bike-Sharing-Systeme kaufen kann.
Habt ihr eins bestellt? Und wenn man jetzt eine Fake-Firma hat, mit Fake-Typografie und Fake-Logo und so weiter, und dann mal sagt, wir brauchen mal Samples, um auszuprobieren, wie die Schlösser eigentlich ausschauen, dann findet man eventuell Hersteller, die einem sowas schicken möchten. Habt ihr gehört?
Ja.
Ich war da nicht beteiligt, also wirklich nicht. Also wirklich nicht. Ich saß nur grinsend dabei, wie U-Bahn-Verlei und Maxi da saßen, und statt U-Bahn-Verlei Fahrradverlei anstreben wollten. Dann kam auf einmal irgendwelche Schlösser über DRL Express mit. Ich musste die Nachname zahlen, weil die nicht da war. Das sind so die kleinen Dinge, die man da lernt. Bestellen, aber nicht da sein, wenn die Nachname kommt. Also jemand hat die Schlösser bestellt, die sind dann zufälligerweise im Verschwörhaus angekommen, als unglücklicherweise.
Und dann? Dann haben wir sie aufgemacht und reingeschaut. Und was an der Stelle eher so witzig war, das sind halt so Rahmschlösser, die man hinten befestigt, was für unsere Fahrradmodelle, die wir im Haus hatten, halt massiv zu groß war. Und wir haben ein bisschen tiefer reingeschaut und haben uns halt auch angeguckt, was wir in der Fürchips verlöteten und den ganzen Kram. Und dann kam raus, das ist eigentlich kein Fahrradschloss, das ist eine Smartwatch. Okay, was da also passiert ist, der Hersteller hat halt auf so einer Plattform, mit der man normalerweise Smartwatches baut, weil das ist halt ganz großartig so, es kann halt irgendwie Bluetooth und es kann halt irgendwie wenig Akku fressen und es hält ewig lange und es kann halt irgendwie nach Hause telefonieren, hat auf der Basis halt eben so ein Bike-Sharing-Schloss, so ein Fahrradschloss gebaut. Und die ursprüngliche Idee ist halt, dass du mit deinem Telefon in die Nähe gehst und dann schickst du per Bluetooth ein Kommando und dann geht's auf. So, natürlich ein bisschen mit mehr Krypto. Hoffentlich. Genug? An der Stelle tatsächlich, wir fanden es okay.
Wenn man es richtig macht.
Wenn man es richtig macht, ja.
Zum Beispiel den Standard-Schlüssel austauscht. Also das System war okay, wenn der, der das System bei sich installiert, dann den Standard-Schlüssel austauscht.
Ja.
Hat jemand mal geguckt, ob bei den bestehenden Fahrrad-Sharing-Systemen Standard-Schlüssel ausgetauscht wurden?
Das ist jetzt vielleicht dann der Spoiler für den Talk morgen. Wir waren ein Jahr später auf der Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht in Karlsruhe und lustigerweise hat ein großes deutsches Bike-Sharing-Unternehmen, das jetzt zufälligerweise in der Stadt dieses Kongresses ist, dort auch Fahrräder stehen. Wir waren ein bisschen verwirrt, weil die haben halt früher alles selber gebaut. Also die hatten hinten so eigene Boardcomputer und irgendwie so ein Zahlenfeld teilweise. Und wir sind da hingekommen und dann sah das Fahrrad halt nicht mehr so aus, wie wir es kannten, sondern es war halt an der Stelle genau das selbe Schloss verbaut, wie wir im Schrank liegen haben.
Und hat dann mal jemand ausprobiert?
Also wir fanden es witzig, wir haben dann das Telefon gesucht, wo die App vom letzten Jahr noch drauf war, mit der wir halt unser eigenes Schloss geöffnet haben und dummerweise, also wir haben drauf gedrückt und es passierte erst nichts und dann waren wir so ein bisschen irritiert und dann haben wir nochmal drauf gedrückt und dann ging das Fahrrad auf.
Und nicht nur eins, sondern es war so klack, klack, klack, klack. Das ist euer Applaus.
Ich war nicht mal dabei.
Es stellte sich halt raus, beim ersten Mal klicken ging halt einfach das Fahrrad 5 Meter weiter auf.
Okay, gut. Dann wusstet ihr also, wie diese Schlösser funktionieren?
Und dann haben wir uns eher mehr so überlegt, naja, in diesen Schlössern werden halt SIM-Karten verbaut. Also im Sinne von, du brauchst halt da so einen Maschine-to-Maschine-Mobilfunk-Tarif. Die werden immer günstiger, aber es ist halt ultra nervig, weil du hast halt mit Mobilfunkanbietern zu tun. Und wir haben in Ulm halt...
Ich hab noch eine Frage zu den Schlössern. Du hast ja erzählt, in dem Schloss drin ist im Prinzip die Platine einer Smartwatch, trotzdem der eigentliche Schließmechanismus.
Ja, es ist ein Motor, der einen Riegel verschiebt.
Wie sicher ist der?
Das haben wir uns angeguckt, das ist halt Vollmetall außenrum. Also wir haben uns mehrere Schlösser angeguckt und bei dem Schloss waren wir relativ okay damit. Also es gab ja damals auch so Anleitungen, wie man einen verbogenen Kleiderbügel in so einen Oberalk reinschiebt. Das gingen, glaube ich, bei der Schlossvariante nicht.
Also aufbohren ist ein...
man kann Dinge tun.
Also es war auf dem Camp... Ich stelle mich daneben, singe einen hohen Ton oder halte eine Batterie irgendwo ran. So was Einfaches nicht. Nein, nein. Es gibt schon einen Angriffsvektor da drauf. Auf dem Camp war das auch ganz witzig, weil dann da raus kam durch Zufall, dass es ganz viele Gruppen gab, die sich auch mit dieser Art von Schlössern und auch mit der Hardware, die in Scootern verbaut ist, die sehr ähnlich ist. Was sich damit machen lässt, und da gab es Ray und MH. Wir waren dann in so einem Zelt drin und haben dann Dinge ausprobiert. Und Ray und MH kamen dann so von wegen, wenn man jetzt ein Stück Plastik nehmen würde und da an der Stelle reinschieben würde und da sind irgendwie Leiterbahnen drauf, dann könnte man an die GPROs drankommen, an die Input-Output-Pins von dieser Platine oder auch an andere Dinge. Oder man könnte auch den Motor bestroben von Extern, wenn man das richtig anstellt. Das geht bei manchen Schlössern tatsächlich. Da gibt es verschiedenste Angriffsvektoren. Es sind ja keine Schlösser, das sind Wegfahrsparren eigentlich. Die sind ja nur erschwerend gegenüber Leinen. Das ist ein interessantes Erforschungsfeld, sag ich mal. Da kann man auch viel tun. Das habt ihr angeguckt und dann die Sache mit den SIM-Karten.
Genau, und da war für mich relativ klar so, naja, ich will eigentlich nicht mit Mobilfunkanbietern spielen. Und wir haben in Ulm das glückliche Feld, dass wir relativ gut abgedeckt sind, was dieses sogenannte LoRaWAN-Netz betrifft.
Was ist das? Low Power Wide Area Network, glaube ich. Also du kannst mit sehr niedrigem Energieaufwand über weite Strecken ganz kleine Datenmengen übertragen. Also nix mit Video-Stream und auch nicht Texten. Du kannst über den Tag verteilt 1-2 SMS verschicken. Aber gerade so Unlock-Kommandos könnte man damit verschicken. Aber das ist sozusagen wie ein WLAN, oder das ist wie Handy-Strahlen. Dann ist es ein 868 MHz-Band, also in dem freien ISM-Band, das man auch für beliebige andere Dinge nutzen kann. Da gibt es ja auch, glaub ich, Cordless-Presenter, wenn man durchklickt in der Präsentation, die sind, glaub ich, auf 2, 4 GHz. Also es gibt Dinge, die auf diesem Band funken, so klassischen Wetterstationen auf 433 MHz. Das ist ein so ein Band, 868 ist das andere. Und da funkt das in Europa. Und das Schöne ist dabei bei der Lorawand-Technik an sich, die ist proprietär. Es gibt aber ein freies Netzwerk, das ist so was wie Freifunk für Sensornetzwerke, wo Menschen sich ein Gateway aufs Dach stellen können. Die sind dann eine Empfangsstation. Es geht mehr ums Empfang von verteilten Sensoren. Und die werden dann ins Internet ausgeleitet und können dann genutzt werden. Das heißt, wenn jemand einen TTN-Sensor, The Things Network, TTN. The Things Network? Genau, das ist dieses freie Netzwerk. Also ein Sensor, der in diesem Netzwerk drin ist. Wenn man den professioniert und z.B. in Berlin benutzt, wo auch eine gute Netzabdeckung da ist und die in einen anderen Standort mitbringt, wo auch TTN, Gateways stehen, dann kann ich da roaming, ich muss da nicht mich neu anmelden. Das ist frei, da können alle mitmachen. Es gibt proprietäre Netzwerke, also geschlossene Netzwerke, auch von kommerziellen Anbietern, so Unity Media und... Okay, warte, wir halten fest. Es gibt in Ulm ein Netzwerk, das man benutzen kann, wenn man weiß, wie es funktioniert. Genau, das ist die Kurzfassung. Dann habt ihr gedacht, das kann man auch mit dem Fahrrad verknüpfen.
Genau, also unser Ding war dann eher so, wir haben dieses Schloss gesehen, das macht Mobilfunk. Diesen ganzen SIM-Karten-Hessel will ich mir nicht geben. Es wäre doch interessant, wenn wir dieses Schloss haben. Wenn das über Lora-Wahn geöffnet werden kann. Und seinen Batteriestatus, seinen aktuellen Gesperrt, seinen Standort versenden kann.
Und dann? Dann gab es ein Hackathon des Verkehrsministeriums. Weil das Verkehrsministerium draufgekommen ist, ist ein grünes Verkehrsministerium in Baden-Württemberg. Dass doch so Verkehrswende schon gut wäre. Ja, Klimakatastrophe, weiß man jetzt auch nicht so genau. Könnte man doch nicht tun. Könnte man ja vielleicht mal machen. Und vor allem, die haben ein ultra gutes Team im Digitalen. Die sind echt gut aufgestellt, finde ich persönlich, im Digitalen Bereich. Und die sagten sich, lass uns doch Formate finden, wo wir halt das ganze wissen, was in der Zivilgesellschaft da ist, was hier auf dem Kongress auch überall rumläuft. Wie wir da mal gucken können, was gibt es da eigentlich alles, wie können wir das Wissen einfach nutzen, um auch den Input mitzunehmen. Normalerweise werden halt so Ministerien beraten von irgendwelchen zwei bis vier Buchstabenagenturen, die dann irgendwie Powerpoints machen und sagen hier, das ist die Blockchain-Strategie, oder lass was mit KI machen, sowas in der Richtung. Und da sind wir zu dritt hingefahren und haben das mal gepitcht. Und daraufhin haben U-Bahn-Verleihe und Maxi ein Stipendium bekommen vom Ministerium, um dieses Feld weiter zu beackern und dann mal rumzuprobieren. Was heißt das konkret? Ihr arbeitet jetzt einen technischen Prototypen, der dann sagt, so geht das jetzt? Oder ihr gründet dann tatsächlich eine Firma? Oder was passiert da?
Wir haben uns tatsächlich die Schlösser genauer angeguckt. Wir haben noch ein paar mehr Schlösser besorgt. Wir haben die Dinge mal zerlegt. Und wir haben angefangen herauszufinden, wie wir Hardware zusammenstecken, wie wir so eine kleine Platine bauen können, um das fertige Schluss zu nehmen. Die Smartwatch da raus, was eigenes rein, was dann halt über Lodawand funkt.
Und ihr habt auf dem Cam schon damit gespielt. Es gab da einen Fahrradverleih, oder?
Genau, das kam auch von uns. Das hieß Death Bike. Und wir haben halt...
Todesfahrrad?
Ne, mit V.
Manche davon waren schon so, weil man sagen könnte, das war schwierig.
Und wir haben halt 14 Tage vor dem Camp oder so mal zu einem Blogpost geschrieben mit Hi, wir würden gerne ein Bike Sharing auf dem Camp machen. Weil irgendwie das Campgelände eignet sich dafür. Und vor allem eignet es sich auch außerhalb vom Camp zum Bahnhof, zum Gelderautomaten, was auch immer zu fahren.
Zum Badesee war ich die häufigste Verwendung.
Und haben dann halt Leute gebeten, wenn zufälligerweise ein Fahrrad bei euch mit dem Zug passt, dann bringt es doch mit. Wenn ihr eins habt, was nicht schlimm ist, wenn es kaputt geht, wenn ihr eins übrig habt zum Scheren, dann bringt es mit. Das haben tatsächlich Leute gemacht und wir sind ultra dankbar dafür. Und tatsächlich haben wir dann, Leute haben uns mehr Fahrräder angeboten, als wir Trecker dabei hatten. Und wir haben halt in den Wochen vor dem Camp noch schnell rudimentär mal Bike Sharing Software zusammengehackt. Also so, wie man es halt kennt. Du hast so eine Oberfläche mit einer Karte und dann siehst du halt, wo stehen Fahrräder rum. Und dann kannst du halt irgendwie draufdrücken, sagen, ich würde dieses gerne ausleihen. Und dann kriegst du halt so einen Zahlenschlusscode zum Beispiel.
Das habt ihr aber, das war ohne Geld oder?
Genau, ja. Also es ging da tatsächlich darum, so kann man eigentlich Bike Sharing selber bauen und wie fühlt sich das an, wenn man das betreibt. Und dann sind wir aufs Camp gekommen, dann sind die Fahrräder so Stück für Stück zu uns gekommen. Und dann haben wir ganz viel Gaffer und ganz viel Kabelbinder genommen und haben Trecker an diese Fahrräder herangemacht. Und haben die dann wieder in die freie Camp-Wildbahn entlassen. Und das vorne klebte halt einfach nur so ein sehr schlecht laminiertes Schild dran, wo dann drauf steht, das ist ein Deathbike, entleih mich, ich habe die Nummer 4. Und tatsächlich haben sich dann übers Camp relativ viele Leute da angemeldet. Wir hatten irgendwas um die 250 Entleihen oder so was.
Wir haben ganz knapp die 256 nicht geschafft. Wie das Chaosradio.
Und Leute sind halt tatsächlich dann da mit Fahrrad rumgefahren. Und wir haben halt wirklich all die Dinge gemacht, die man halt so in den ersten Tagen als klassischen Bikesharer auch lernt. Das heißt, wir haben in der ersten Nacht alle unsere Fahrräder verloren, weil bei den Trackern die Akkus leer gingen und wir das Monitoring zu spät dafür online hatten. Und haben die dann halt durch Wild rumfahren und Leute darauf aufmerksam machen, halt wir alle eingesammelt und Akkus getauscht und so. Und dann kamen halt über die Campzeit immer mehr Leute, die es halt nicht nur interessant fanden, sondern dann halt auch gemeint haben, hier, ich hätte da mal ein Pull Request für euch. Ich hätte da eine Verbesserung.
Pull Request heißt, sie wollten was zum Code beitragen.
Genau. Und so hatten wir dann zum Beispiel auch gegen Ende des Camps so eine Art Chaos Login über Eventphone. Also über das Deck-System, was halt damit auch funktionierte, wenn du halt keinen Twitter oder keinen Frag den Staat Account hattest.
Genau, muss man dazu sagen, also Login, es gibt keine eigene Benutzerverwaltung an der Stelle, sondern man loggt sich mit einem anderen Identitätsprovider ein und das war am Anfang Twitter und Frag den Staat hat irgendwann auch die Identitätsmöglichkeit dazugefügt noch während des Camps und Eventphone war dann auch möglich. Das ist ja aber sozusagen, wenn so Hacker und Hackerinnen zusammenkommen und da stellt jemand ein Ding zur Verfügung, was mit Schlössern zu tun hat. Gibt es da wahrscheinlich so ein gewisses Interesse? Hattet ihr da besondere Erlebnisse? Nö, eigentlich nicht. Also ich meine, das ist die arschlochfreie Zone, die klassische auf solchen Veranstaltungen, von daher... Nee, so meinte ich das gar nicht. Man guckt sich das ja wahrscheinlich trotzdem und denkt, na mal gucken, was da geht und wenn ich halt was finde, dann kann ich ja Bescheid sagen. Ja, also ich sag mal, es waren jetzt nicht diese Sharing-Schlösser, die da verbaut worden sind, sondern klassische Zahlenschlösser. Und natürlich könnte man die picken, aber oft waren die Fahrräder auch einfach unverschlossen rumgestanden. Die wurden eher verschlossen, wenn sie draußen waren. Von daher gab es auch viel mehr Fahrten vermutlich. Die haben sich auch bewegt, ohne dass jemand das so offiziell ausgeliehen hat. Von daher war das kein Stress. Das war wirklich nur so ein Prototypen-Test. Es ging um Daten, also um Wissen sammeln, so genau. Und woran könnte man sich das weiterentwickeln? Also gibt es, wenn man an Fahrrad-Sharing denkt, gibt es da so eine Art auch, ich weiß gar nicht, ist nur einer ins total Blaue gesprochen, die so ein Open, nicht Open Source ist Quatsch, sondern ein Open-Material-Gedanken, also im Sinne von, man könnte ja ein Fahrrad-Sharing aufmachen, wo auch jeder sein Fahrrad reinmacht, oder ist das schon jetzt sozusagen im Sinne von, wir wollen eigentlich mal rausfinden, wie man das auch betreibt und dann auch als Einbetreiber? Das ist sehr witzig, weil die Frage von wegen, ich könnte mein eigenes Fahrrad da reingeben in die Pool, die begegnen uns immer wieder. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so funktioniert tatsächlich, weil Menschen ja schon eher emotional an ihren eigenen Fahrrädern hängen und möchten dann nicht, also die möchten mit ihrem Fahrrad fahren, im Zweifelsfall. Ich könnte mir eher vorstellen, dass solche Modelle funktionieren auf so genossenschaftlicher Basis. Also dass man sagt, ich habe eine Nachbarschaft, wir schmeißen zusammen und rollen mal zehn Fahrräder aus. Und das System, was jetzt gerade in der Entwicklung ist, es ist noch ein bisschen weitergegangen, hat einen größeren Umfang angenommen, wäre auch perspektivisch darauf angelegt, zu sagen, ich kann hier rollen. Also ich kann sagen, ich habe wegen mir die Stadtteilgenossenschaft A und die Stadtteilgenossenschaft B, die sind in anderen Stadtteilen, die kümmern sich um ihre Fahrräder und gucken, dass da Luft drin ist und dass die verkehrssicher sind usw. Aber ich kann dazwischen rollen. Faktisch ein Verbund von Genossenschaften zum Beispiel. Aber wollt ihr was bauen, wo ihr denn der Betreiber seid? Oder wollt ihr was bauen, wo ihr sagt, hier schaut? Ihr habt ja am Anfang erzählt, auf Alibaba gibt es Leute, die verkaufen Fahrertragensysteme. Oder wollt ihr eine Art Datenbank machen oder Anleitung für hier? So könnte ein Fahrertragensystem sein.
Ich glaube eher nicht so Betreiber. Weil am Ende muss man sich um Fahrräder kümmern. Da komme ich zu viel aus der Software-Ecke. Ja, könnte ich mir jetzt aufschaffen, aber dafür bastle ich es. Sehr gerne Software. Was ich gerne hätte, ist tatsächlich ein Open Source Bike Sharing System. Aktuell regelt der Markt da nicht so. Also müssen wir halt selber. Dann ist es aber so, dass wenn wir schon ein Open Source Bike Sharing System bauen, dass wir es halt eher so nach unseren Vorstellungen bauen können. Und dass es halt genau vielleicht auch die Sachen machen, die jetzt bei den kommerziellen Anbietern gerade schiefgehen. Oder die, die da halt nicht gut funktionieren. Und das von Stefan angesprochene Roaming wäre halt eines so. Also das ist halt wie bei den Scootern oder bei den Car Shareern auch so. Warum, wenn ich in eine andere Stadt fahre, brauche ich schon wieder 20 neue Apps? Das muss doch nicht sein.
Ich glaube, was da noch ein bisschen der Hintergrund fehlt oder dazugehört, ist dieses Gesamtheitlich-Denken eigentlich. Ich habe ein Verkehrssystem und ich möchte eigentlich, also mein eigentlicher Anspruch ist, ich möchte mein Mobilitätsbedürfnis befriedigen. Ich möchte von Tür zu Tür fahren und auf dem Weg kann ich mit einer Mitfahrgelegenheit fahren und die letzte Meile dann mit Bike Sharing machen, sonst irgendwie. Das muss aber alles irgendwie mit möglichst einem Klick erreichbar sein. Und das Ziel ist gerade nicht jetzt diese Superportal-Plattform zu machen, sonst irgendwie, sondern dazu beizutragen, dass es ganz viele dezentrale Anbieter von Mobilitätslösungen gibt, die aber über offene Schnittstellen ihre Informationen rausspielen und dann eben verknüpft sind durch Dritte, durch beliebige Dritte. Also nicht BTX, wo es einen zentralen Anbieter gibt. Und das ist dann so am besten noch eine Bundespost sonst irgendwie, sondern wirklich der klassische Internet-Ansatz dezentral. Und ich kann mal das Zeug zusammensuchen. So eine Art Java für Fahrräder? Nee, mit mehr Nutzern. Es muss auch für normale Menschen außerhalb dieses Daums nutzbar sein. Ich habe noch eine konkrete Fahrradfrage. Am Anfang hat man über die Berge in der Stadt gesprochen. Und dass da auch ein Elektromotor ganz praktisch wäre am Fahrt. Wir haben bis jetzt nur über das Schloss und die Ausleimichanlage gesprochen. Gerade bei diesem Genossenschaftlichen könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, ist das mitgedacht oder ist das auch ein Plan, dass man sagt, das überwacht auch, wie dick die Batterie gerade noch am Start ist. Und dann gibt es noch so eine, ich kann auch selber aufladen, Strom spenden für das Fahrradsystem oder so. Das ist durchaus alles denkbar, aber in dem Stadium sind wir eigentlich gleich. Wir haben jetzt das große Glück, dass wir 25 Fahrräder, also wirklich gute Fahrräder auch beschaffen konnten dafür und die es gerade ausrollen. Im Kontext ist gerade, ich arbeite bei einer kleinen Stadtverwaltung, die zufällig auch in Ulm ist. Und wir hatten die Gelegenheit, da jetzt nochmal eine Förderung zu holen und dann so kompetente Menschen wie Maxi und im U-Bahn-Verleih als Fellows in die Stadt reinzuholen, die ein Jahr lang genau das jetzt gerade tun. Und ausrollen mit Menschen einfach. Und dann wirklich mal, dass man nicht nur nach Feierabend 2-3 Stunden macht, sondern wirklich mal kontinuierlich wirklich dranbleiben kann und das ausrollt. Aber auch mit dem Ansatz, das dann wieder anderen Hackspaces, also die mit einzubeziehen, denen das dann hinzugeben, zum Testen mit anderen Bedingungen einfach, damit da wirklich ein Ökosystem, wirklich ein Open Source Ökosystem draus werden kann. Okay, so, also du arbeitest noch mit einem Kollegen in diesem Stipendium? Zu dritt insgesamt seid ihr. Wenn man jetzt nicht nach Ulm fahren will, um das Fahrrad auszuleihen, wie kann man das Projekt weiterverfolgen oder unter Umständen vielleicht sogar was beitragen oder sich zumindest das, was es gibt, schon übernehmen, um selber damit zu freckeln?
Also angefangen und so ein bisschen Doku bzw. so diese ganzen Hintergründe werden erklärt auf radforschung.org. Irgendwo in der Assembly hatten wir auch Sticker, wo drauf steht Schloss mit lustig. Sonst tatsächlich eben auf den GitHub Accounts, also github.com/radforschungundtatsächlich github.com/stadtulm.
Und ulm.dev, da ist noch eine Ähnlichkeit mit ulm.de ist zufällig, aber das ist ein Domain für immer. Entschuldigung, def. Das ist schön, wenn man eine ähnliche Domain selber in der Hand hat und nicht mit der städtischen IT damit reden muss. Ja, das ist ultravortragend. Da ist auch eine Projektbeschreibung einfach drauf. Genau, und wir haben auch schon Kontakt zu Hackspaces, die Lust haben, die zum Teil auch schon mit Hardware forschen. Wer da Lust hat, auf jeden Fall gar nicht. Weil das kann nur funktionieren langfristig, wenn es ein Community-Projekt ist. Sehr schön. Das klingt sehr spannend. Ich bin gespannt, wann zum ersten Mal ein Bediener in dieser Serie da auftaucht. Oder vielleicht auch Roller. Das steht schon eigentlich da. Das ist übrigens total spannend, weil seit es diese E-Roller gibt, habe ich das Gefühl, ich möchte die gerne mal ausprobieren. Dann installiere ich mir immer die App und dann komme ich zu dieser Datenschutz-Klärin, da denke ich so, nee. Also vielleicht, wenn ihr das dahin ausgehend sozusagen ausweiten könntet, dann könnt ihr vielleicht endlich mal E-Roller fahren. Das würde mich sehr freuen. Ansonsten vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart und das uns erzählt und geteilt habt. So, und jetzt werden wir viele wurde angekündigt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir jetzt noch mehr, mehr Leute als Mikrofone oder weniger. Es geht jetzt um eine Kommune Kollektiv. Ich muss noch genauer rausfinden. Eins Kommune heißt es auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, das sind die falschen Mikrofone. Ich glaube, ihr müsst hierher kommen. Es sollte so aussehen, wie das, was ich auf dem Kopf habe. Wenn das auch vor eurem Gesicht hängt, dann ist es das Richtige. Genau, kommt her in den Platz. Nein, das ist Anarchisten, das merkt man gleich. So, hi. In der Eskalationsstufe, Marcus redet über Dinge, über die er nichts weiß. Wir geben uns jetzt noch einen Schritt weiter. Wir haben im Chaosradio Team, vielen Dank übrigens an alle, die bei der Vorbereitung mitgeholfen haben, darüber gesprochen, was könnte interessant sein. Und ich so, ja, eins, Kona, voll interessantes Projekt. Was ist denn das eigentlich? Das habe ich auch gefragt, das konnte mir keiner so richtig genau sagen. Gibt es hier jemanden, der das vielleicht erläutern kann?
Kona ist ein kollektiver Ansatz, sich zu organisieren, Stimmung, Verantwortung mit dem Ego zurück zu schrauben, zuhören, zuhören, aufpassen, die paar Streiten und Lieben gleichzeitig zu teilen.
Aber die Frage, die ich dann an der Stelle hätte, ist, wenn alle immer durcheinander reden, wie funktioniert das denn?
Das ist mich erstaunlich.
Komplexes Zuhören. Komplexes Zuhören, komplexes Sprechen. Viel zu weniger. Viel zu leise eigentlich.
Das ist interessant, weil mir erzählen oft Leute, sie würden Podcasts zum Einschlafen hören, was ich total unfassbar finde, weil ich das selber nicht kann. Wenn eine Stimme verständliche Worte redet, dann muss ich dazuhören und kann dabei unmöglich einschlafen. Aber dieses Susurum von der Stimme fand ich sehr beruhigend. Dieses Mikrofon hier scheint mir gar nicht anzusehen. Könnten wir da vielleicht noch mal sagen? Noch eine Stimme.
Dann hat eins ja gar nicht gehört, wie du vorhin von den Handstandinnen gesprochen hast.
Ja, ich hab sie nicht von den Handstandinnen erzählt.
Und von den Männern.
Ja, Komona besteht hauptsächlich aus Feuerwehrmännerinnen, Pfotzen und Pfotzeninnen und Pfotzausen.
Das scheint mir eine bunte Truppe, wenn ich das mal so garnehme. Aber ok, da scheint nicht klarbar ist, was das ist. Vielleicht im Rahmen des Kongresses, wo ist denn eins Komona hier? Und wie sieht es aus?
Das ist ein Pizzastück, da könnt ihr vorbeikommen, mitessen und mitmachen.
Wo denn?
Also es ist so eine Ansammlung von verschiedenen Spaces in Halle 2. Ihr findet das auch über die Navigations-App tatsächlich unter 1 Komona. Und es ist ein schöner Ort, also wir laden euch alle ein, da mal vorbeizukommen und einfach die verschiedenen Initiativen, die es dort gibt, auch kennenzulernen und einfach mitzumachen, weil wie gesagt wurde bei der Komona geht es sehr viel um Organisierung und das ist ein offenes Prozess. Also Selbstorganisierung ist auch etwas, was wir alle lernen wollen und müssen.
Wie gut funktioniert das?
Also ich hatte gestern um 4.00 Uhr früh voll den Aufräumdrang und hab einfach die Bierflaschen aufgeräumt. Das war eigentlich ganz okay.
Also es gibt ungefähr 732, 2 Pets, in denen irgendwelche Informationen stehen. Und die haben auch alle mehrere Passwörter. Und nur manche Leute haben auch Zugang zu diesen Passwörtern und andere Leute haben Zugang zu diesen Pets.
Also eigentlich haben schon alle Zugänge zu allen, aber man muss sich drum kümmern.
Aber eigentlich ist letzten Endes noch ganz egal, was da steht.
Ja, weil wenn wir da sind, dann ist es eh egal.
Ist es ein Projekt, das nur dem Ergründen der Möglichkeiten und Unmöglichkeiten von Selbstorganisation dient? Oder gibt es auch Dinge, die ihr außer die Möglichkeiten und Unmöglichkeiten von Selbstorganisation mit dem Publikum auf dem Chaos Communication Congress teilen wollt?
Ich glaube nicht an das Konzept von Publikum.
Also der Punkt ist halt, in dem Moment, in dem du einen Comuna betrittst, bist du auch Teil von Comuna. Ein Raum, eine Situation ist immer von allen getragen, die in dem Moment da sind. So wie wir jetzt alle in dem Raum auch Teil von diesem Gespräch sind. Und irgendwie funktioniert das in Comuna nicht so gut mit einfach kommen und konsumieren.
Also ich glaube, dass jeder, der oder die in Comuna betritt, ganz viel Inhalt mitbringt. Und natürlich ist die Challenge die Selbstorganisation von ganz viel Inhalten davon.
Also ich glaube, wenn so dieser Anspruch von Dezentralisierung irgendwie ernst genommen werden soll, dann heißt das ja, dass ganz viele Leute befähigt sind, sich auch dezentral zu organisieren. Das ist ja auch so ein Anspruch.
Also wenn man das aus der technischen Perspektive betrachtet, funktioniert die Dezentralisierung vor allen Dingen dadurch, dass man sich auf Protokolle geeignet hat, also auf eine gemeinsame Sprache, die man spricht. Und die im technischen Sinne für alle dasselbe bedeutet. Das scheint mir jetzt hier nicht so toll der Fall zu sein.
Ja, es gibt jeden Abend ein Plenum, aber da geht auch eigentlich nicht so viele Leute hin. Wir versuchen das so weit zu dezentralisieren, dass wir ein delegiertes System hätten, wo quasi Leute als verschiedenen Infinity Groups ihre Abgesandten ans Plenum schicken können und die dann wieder zurückreporten können. Aber das mit der gemeinsamen Sprache nun Menschen sind ja zum Glück keine Technik. Und damit das Menschsein besonders gut funktioniert, ist es wichtig, Strukturen zu erschaffen, in denen mit verschiedenen Sprachen gearbeitet werden kann. Und eine dezentrale Struktur, die das Menschsein ernst nimmt, hat keine gemeinsame Sprache.
Aber ist es da noch eine Struktur?
Es ist halt was anderes. Es ist so ein flexibles Ding aus verschiedenen Beziehungen.
Was mir tatsächlich ein bisschen komisch vorkommt, ist, dass mir gefühlt die ganze Zeit erklärt wird, warum das keine funktionierende, festgelegte Struktur oder Kommunikation ist. Warum gibt es dann überhaupt diesen Ort und diesen Namen, der ja etwas vereinigt, was es eigentlich gar nicht zu geben scheint?
Doch, es gibt schon einen zusammen. Und das ist halt einfach, dass sich darauf einigen, dass man diesen Ort bespielt. Und darauf zu einigen, dass jeder dieser Gruppen, die dort einen Ort bespielt, es gibt ja verschiedene Bereiche, verschiedene sozusagen Doms oder Zonen oder Orte, die von unterschiedlichen Gruppen genutzt bespielt werden, dass sozusagen der gemeinsame Verantwortung für diesen Ort sozusagen übernommen wird und dass auch Leute, die dazukommen, eingeladen werden, mit Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Also das ist vielleicht so etwas, was schon so eine Art Grundsatz ist. Also das sozusagen wie diesen be excellent to each other. Also dass wir das halt auf diesen Ort umlegen und sagen, ja, diese Zone, die eine Kommune für uns ist, ist ein Ort, wo wir wirklich gut miteinander umgehen wollen und wo verschiedene Gruppen sich dazu committen, gemeinsam Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Und gerade das mit dem vereinheitlichten Namen, das geht ja vor allem um Ansprechbarkeit von außen. Nach innen geht es ja nicht da. Also, damit von außen über was geredet werden kann, braucht es ja ein Wort. Und gegen innen hin ist es ja erstmal egal, ob man ein gemeinsames Wort hat oder nicht. Viel wichtiger ist der gemeinsame Wille.
Das finde ich das verwundere, weil es gibt dieses gemeinsame Wort. Und wegen des gemeinsamen Wortes seid ihr jetzt auch hier. Aber jede Frage, die man stellt, im Versuch, das gemeinsame Wort zu verstehen, wird damit beantwortet, es gibt nichts gemeinsames, was wir so erklären können, dass es dieses Wort erklärt. Das ist mein Verständnisproblem an der Stelle.
Ich komme gerade aus einem zweistündigen Workshop, der hieß, Comuna, What is it even? Und es sind sehr verschiedene Antworten dabei rausgekommen. Das Comuna existiert nicht seit, oder ja, nein, beides gleichzeitig, seit jetzt fast drei Jahren. Und darin gibt es aber, es gibt eine Kontinuität und gleichzeitig gibt es sie halt auch nicht. Also genauso wie der Kongress eine Kontinuität hat und gleichzeitig halt auch nicht. Also es geht ja quasi darum, es gibt nicht nur Zeit und Raum, sondern es gibt ja auch als dritte Konstituente quasi die Beziehungsweisen, die zwischen den Menschen entstehen, die Arten des Umgangs miteinander. Und das ist irgendwie das, was sich halt für eine Sprache fassen lässt, weil das etwas ist, worüber noch nicht so viel gesprochen wird oder was noch nicht so, was auch etwas ist, was sich die ganze Zeit verändert und was aber genauso eine Situation mitbestimmt wie Raum und Zeit.
Aber es ist, im Endeffekt ist Komono ja auch nicht so abstrakt. Es ist tatsächlich ein sehr realer Ort, wo initiativen Dinge tun und wo einfach Sachen passieren. Also es gibt dort einfach auch Spaces für Workshops, es gibt verschiedene Gruppen, die bestimmte Dinge vermitteln wollen und das ist dann wieder das sehr Konkretes und es geht natürlich darum, dieses Miteinander zueinander zu verhandeln und ja, gut, das halt gut zu machen. Und halt so zu machen, wie wir uns auch Gesellschaft vorstellen. Also zum Beispiel halt solidarisch.
So langweilig, dieses ganze ernste Gelaber hier.
Man würde die Kritik an dem Gelaber viel besser verstehen, wenn du den Mikrofon nicht immer wegmachen würdest. Du bist auch von der technischen Struktur, das tut mir sehr leid, aber du musst dich hier unterwerfen, wenn du gehört werden willst.
Also konkret gehört werden möchtest.
Ja, ich finde es gerade ein bisschen zu ernst. Und so ein bisschen, glaube ich, ist es auch ganz okay, dass das so ephämie ist.
Aber ich frage mich, wie inklusiv ist das? Also wenn ihr in ein Ort sein wolltet...
Bloß nicht inklusiv, das bedeutet immer exklusiv zu sein.
Warum?
Ja, inklusiv, exklusiv.
Du kannst natürlich den Satz nochmal wiederholen, aber warum? Warum ist es sozusagen exklusiv, wenn man...
Weil inklusiv davon ausgeht, dass wir gleich sein können. Und wir können alle nicht gleich sein.
Das ist nun alle unterschiedlich.
Okay, halt, ich bin jetzt auf einer Diskussion. Ich denke, ich hätte das eher verstanden als, ihr wolltet ein Ort sein, also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ein Ort sein, wo man auch hinkommen kann und dann tatsächlich auch Teil dieses Ortes ist. Das kann man natürlich Qualdefinition immer festlegen und sagen, wenn du hier bist, dann bist du auch da. Aber ich freu mich natürlich schon, wenn man zu so einem Ort kommt, wie befremdlich und damit sozusagen abstoßend wirkt das. Also im Sinne von, dass ich mich meiner selbst gar nicht angenommen fühle an diesem Ort, der eigentlich für alle da sein will. Und welche Rolle das für euch spielt, ob dieses Gefühl ausgelöst wird oder nicht. Gesellschaftlicher Konsens. Frieden auf der Welt durch Bällebad. Das könnte funktionieren. Ein paar Sachen hab ich gehört. Es gibt bei euch eine Polizeiklasse.
Todesleite, ja.
Was ist das und warum?
Es gibt die Polizeiklasse. Ein interdisziplinäres Künstlerinnen-Kollektiv. Aufgrund der neuen Polizeiaufgabengesetze, die 2017 und 2018 in Bayern novelliert worden sind. Jetzt auch auf andere Bundesländer zu kommen werden. Oder auch schon umgesetzt worden sind. Diese Gruppierung hat sich vorgenommen, in so legalen Bereichen und gewaltfrei zu intervenieren. In öffentlichen Raum. Und das sichtbar zu machen. Also eher so eine Informationsoffensive und Mobi-Aktionen zu planen.
Ich finde schon, dass wir das nur machen, weil es cool ist.
Also würdet ihr sagen, die Polizeiklasse ist eher so peng oder eher Political Beauty?
Beides überhaupt nicht, weil das Zeital neoliberalisiert ist.
Sondern?
Es geht vielmehr um eine Bewegung eigentlich. Es geht darum, die Politisierung weiter voranzutreiben. Deswegen müssen wir Mittel und Wege finden, künstlerische Werkzeuge an die Hand zu geben, die vervielfältigbar sind und auch nicht irgendwie ein großartig, unglaublich schön designtes Mahnmal vor dem Bundestag darstellen, das unglaublich aufwändige Planung braucht und Ressourcen, sondern die Kunst ist eine Verbündete von uns allen. Und deswegen müssen wir uns beibringen, sie alle zu nutzen. Und es geht nicht darum, dass man ganz designt einfach nur...
Ja, und es geht halt wahrscheinlich auch um Sprache oder den Versuch... Sprache ist auch exklusiv wahrscheinlich, aber Bilder wahrscheinlich auch. Aber auch Menschen zu erreichen, die vielleicht gewohnte Bilder aus einer eher linken oder anarchischen Strömung nicht so verstehen oder nicht annehmen können. Und die möchte man ja erreichen, damit die auch anfangen, darüber nachzudenken, ob sie Teil sein möchten von einer Gewaltfreien Gesellschaft.
Ist das noch Konzeptarbeit oder habt ihr schon ein Beispiel für sozusagen so ein künstlerisches Werkzeug, das man an die Hand geben kann?
Was supergut ist, jeder von uns hat zum Beispiel Bluetooth-Boxen und jeder von uns hat einen Computer und kann so ein Mikro oder so ein Ding, was du da auch hast, ja an den Kopf schnallen und mal so einen Text einsprechen. Und das kann ja jegliche Forderung sein, ich hoffe, ich will, dass die Leute einfach ein bisschen mehr pupsen in der U-Bahn oder so oder sich einfach ein bisschen anders entspannen oder tatsächlich, wenn sie wirklich politische Forderungen haben, können sie das ja auch irgendwie verschriftlichen und vertonen und das zum Beispiel mit ihren Freunden in der U-Bahn teilen über diese besagten Bluetooth-Lautsprecher. Super simpel, funktioniert, kotzt einige Leute an, ziemlich witzig, macht Spaß.
Also ganz ehrlich, bis jetzt kommt es mir so vor, als ob es vor allen Dingen um Irritation geht.
Ich glaube, wenn es die richtigen Inhalte sind, dann geht es natürlich in gewisser Weise darum, diese Bubbles und diese kleinen Tunnel, in denen man sich im Alltag bewegt, zu stören. Und das ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so unwichtig, weil...
Nee, das ist ab... Ich verstehe sozusagen, dass man das so definieren kann. Aber es kommt mir so vor, als ginge es um die Irritation der Irritation willen. Nee, wir haben ja auch... Zum Beispiel für alle, die Podcast nur hören und nicht sehen. Im Hintergrund wälzen sich gerade so zwei oder drei Leute, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, herum. Ich kenne die auch nicht. Und strecken ihre Füße in die Luft. Das sind möglicherweise schöne Füße, aber es hat halt sozusagen an sich, für mich zumindest, keine Aussage, sondern es ist vor allen Dingen eine Irritation. Die aber den Zweck einer Irritation hat und sonst nichts. Und so kommt mir das halt auch vor, momentan.
Aber wenn du sagst und sonst nichts, dann klingt das ja so sehr erwärtend auf mich jetzt gerade. Und ich frage mich, was wäre denn dieses sonst, was du erwartest?
Einen Beitrag zu der Sendung, die wir hier machen. Machen wir doch. Ich verstehe diesen Beitrag nicht, deswegen kommen sie sofort.
Also ich hab einfach keine Ahnung vom Kunst vielleicht. Aber Irritation und Provokation sind einfach ein paar gewisse Stilmittel, die man anwenden kann. Und man kann Sachen appropriieren. Und es gibt so viele wiege, Gewege künstlerisch zu agieren. Und das ist jetzt die Irritation, die Irritation will. Und das ist die Irritation, die man sich anwenden kann. Ach, wenn da auf einmal Flugblätter von Münchner Rathaus fliegen, die einfach auf eine Demo hinweisen und die neuen Polizeiaufgabengesetze, dann ist das schon recht informativ und dadurch, dass man das dann halt im heutigen Zeitalter natürlich auch ein bisschen frameen kann und es soziale Medien gibt, auf denen man das teilen kann, kann man dadurch viel mehr Leute erreichen und vielleicht auch mit einem gewissen Charme letztendlich auch Leute erreichen, die sich nicht ansonsten für dieses Thema interessiert hätten. Dafür zum Beispiel haben wir dieses, ich hab vielleicht überall diese Nein-Sticker gesehen hier, haben wir so ein Label entworfen, dass es dadurch entstanden ist. So was ist der Slogan, den wir nutzen können, um dem ganzen irgendwie vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr Pepp zu geben? Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, nein. So vier Worte, ganz klar, meine ich doch. Ist alles das gleiche. Inklusiv, exklusiv, aber ja. Und dann haben die gesagt, ne, finden sie alle scheiße. Und deswegen haben wir es einfach selber gemacht. Und jetzt findet sich dieses Nein halt doch wieder. Das dürfen auch alle Leute benutzen. Das findet ihr auf unserer Webseite polizeiklasse.org. Da könnt ihr das Nein herunterladen, es vervielfältigen, es in andere Kontexte mit einbringen, euch fetzige T-Shirts drucken oder euch das Gesicht tätowieren, wie auch immer.
Das Nein herunterladen, das find ich auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr, sehr schöner Satz.
Oder halt so konkretere Sachen wie die cop-map.de, Menschen, die von Polizeigewalt oder Repression jeden Tag betroffen sind, nur weil sie nicht weiß sind oder so, einfach unterstützen und helfen, damit sie wissen, wo ist jetzt gerade die Polizei, wo kann ich sie jetzt vermeiden, sodass sie ganz schnell in die Arbeit kommen, ohne Verspätung. Gibt's auch. Das habe ich mit dem Pengel zusammen gemacht. Die haben dann auch Ressourcen und Wissen. Man geht in Zusammenarbeit oder Austausch. Man kann sich auch gegenseitig unterstützen als Gruppierungen.
Und die Polizeiklasse ist also ein Bewohner, das ist eigentlich ein kollektiven Ort. Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Jemand hat heute geschrieben, eine Intergalactic Dome Exhibition.
Okay, also die Polizeiklasse ist ein Aufstellungsstück in der Intergalactic Dome Exhibition. Was gibt es noch?
Das ist kein Stück, ja.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel...
Was sind die Bestandteile einer Exhibition?
Nein, wir sind so nicht da.
Wir bewegen uns.
Aber lassen wir doch die anderen auch mal sprechen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel die Spieleberatung, es gibt zum Beispiel auch Reclaim Club Culture und Chaos Ballett. Und die Dezentrale als Ort, wo die sich treffen. Magst du was sagen zum Chaos Ballett?
Ich mag was sagen zu Reclaim Club Culture. Das ist ein Bündnis von Clubbetreiberinnen, Aktivistinnen, Menschen, die im Clubs in Berlin mostly arbeiten, dann Forscherinnen und das Netzwerk ist angetreten, um emanzipatorische Praxis in der Clubkultur einen Diskussionsraum zu geben. Und hat dann 2018 eine Demonstration namens AFD Wegbassen initiiert, wo auf einmal die gesamte alternative, ein bisschen schwieriges Wort, aber alternative Club Szene in Berlin aktiv wurde und 70.000 Leute mobilisiert hat, um gegen die AFD zu demonstrieren in einem politischen Klima, wo die traditionelle Linke, zu der ich mich nicht zählen will, oder wir uns nicht nicht zählen will, ein Mobilisierungsproblem hatte und wir durch einen alternativen Gesellschaftsentwurf sehr viel bunten Protest, diversen Protest auf die Straße getragen haben und seitdem nicht nur innerhalb der Clubkultur aktiv sind, sondern auch außerhalb und Protest auf die Straße tragen, um auch klar zu machen, was haben wir auch durch einen Rechtsruck zu verlieren und wie können wir antifaschistische Kämpfe in Räume, die es vielleicht vorher nicht betroffen hat, wieder klar machen. Und da ist ja auch letztes Jahr auch am CCC die Diskussion durch die Platzierung der Antifa Flagge im Eingang aufgekommen. Und das sehe ich halt so als Räume, wo irgendwie andere Lebensentwürfe gelebt werden. Die sind jetzt auch an dem Punkt, wo wir uns irgendwie zu positionieren müssen. Um gegen eine Faschistisierung der Gesellschaft zu arbeiten. Und da arbeiten wir in ganz unterschiedlichen Kontexten. Also wir sind sehr viel aktivistisch unterwegs, aber wir arbeiten auch in die Community rein um Themen wie Erwähnnis und Themen wie, wie können wir uns vor Polizeirepressionen auf linke Strukturen schützen? Also wie können wir auch, es geht auch sehr viel um Wissenstransfer. Wir arbeiten sehr viel mit How-To's, um Menschen zu ermöglichen, wie sie oder dass, dass sie auch Dinge tun können. Also da gibt es überhaupt keine Autorinnenschaft, deswegen sitze ich jetzt als Person auch, für alle die es nicht sehen, sehr verkleidet hier, weil ich heute also Rosa Rafe hier bin, die antifaschistische Clubaktivistin aus der Zukunft, die eine kollektive Stimme ist und von sehr unterschiedlichen Personen in unterschiedlichen Rollen gespielt wird. Und heute bin ich eben die, die es spielt.
Das Reclaim the Club Culture bezieht sich also darauf, dass die sozusagen Räume der Unterhaltung und des hedonismus wieder antifaschistisch werden? Oder geht es auch um die Strukturen, in denen Club leben? Also weil du jetzt Berlin als Beispiel oder ihr Berlin als Beispiel angebracht habt, geht es auch darum?
Na ja, also Club Kultur ist ja tatsächlich gegründet worden oder entstanden, durch ein Begehren, alternative Lebenskonzepte zu leben.
Wenn man so sagt, aus der Stadtperspektive, das rechnet sich ja gerade nicht mehr.
Genau, es gibt ja gerade und deswegen sage ich ja auch, wir sind sehr in Berlin aktiv. Es gibt ja gerade in Berlin doch durchaus noch einige Clubs und Strukturen, die nicht auf Verwertung aus sind, sondern eben kollektiv organisiert sind, was mega anstrengend ist, was mega viel Zeit braucht, was auch keinerlei großen Profit irgendwie abwirft. Aber diese Orte gibt es noch und diese Orte sind von Gentrifizierung enorm bedroht. Das ist auch ein Thema, an dem wir sehr viel arbeiten. Linke und alternative Orte im stadtpolitischen Kontext, deren Wichtigkeit sozusagen eine Lobby zu geben, weil es einfach wirklich wie eine Schneelawine, das ist Neoliberalismus sozusagen, diese Orte auch bedroht sind. Und da geht es wirklich um Mietverträge, da geht es um, wenn ich mich entscheide, nicht meine Getränke zu sponsern, sondern einfach nur Getränke verkaufen will, dann habe ich halt schon einen Wettbewerbsnachteil. Und es sind wirklich kleine Dinge. Und diese Orte, die sich aber im Reclaim Club Culture vernetzen, versuchen eben nicht nur auf diese consumer orientierte Club Kultur, also sich davon abzugrenzen. Und eben wie Comona auch, alle Personen, die an einem Abend in den Club kommen, sind nicht nur Consumer, sondern es geht um be excellent to each other, es geht wirklich um Prinzipien zu leben und sich ausprobieren zu können dadurch, weil wir gut zueinander sind.
Was ich hier so ein bisschen durchsitze, ich hab das Einschlag auch noch gehört, was mich persönlich auch interessiert, Spieleberatung. Kann mir dazu jemand was erklären? Na ja, es geht um Spiele anscheinend. Spielen finde ich interessant. Was macht das in dem Kontext? Was ist die Spieleberatung? Wen berät sie, was zu spielen?
Ja, die Spieleberatung ist vor allem erst mal eine Art zu denken. Und wir beschäftigen uns ganz doll mit Kommunikationsstrukturen, mit Sprache, mit Narrativ und mit Regeln. Also alles das, was quasi ein Spiel in seinen einzelnen Teilen ausmacht. Und das fließt dann auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen in verschiedene Umgebungen ein. Und das schafft so Spielräume, also die Möglichkeit überhaupt ins Spiel zu kommen. Wem berät die Spieleberatung? Ja, große Frage. Also eigentlich alle, die wollen oder die spielen wollen oder nicht spielen wollen, können sich beraten lassen. Aber das klingt dann halt so direkt nach so einer hierarchischen Situation. Meistens ist es eigentlich so, dass die Konzepte oder die, wenn man das jetzt Spiele nennen will, die Spiele der Spieleberatung darauf ausgelegt sind, dass sie eigentlich selber von den Spielenden mitgestaltet werden können. Also weil das eigentlich am Spielen, im Englischen gibt es da die schöne Unterscheidung zwischen Game and Play und das schöne am Spielen ist eigentlich das Spannende, ist ja immer dann, wenn ich in der Position bin, dass ich die Regeln während ich spiele ändere.
Das ist dann also eher das Play, das freie Spiel.
Das freie Spiel.
Das Regellose.
Nee, ist eben nicht regellos. Das ist ja das Interessante. Das Regel Dynamische, also die Regeln brechen sich quasi immer selbst, also das merkt man ja, wenn man selbst in so einem Alltagsspiel drin ist, weiß eins ja auch nicht so genau, wo das jetzt hinführt. Also nicht das zielorientierte Spielen, sondern...
Das klingt sehr spannend, das klingt vor allen Dingen auch, dass man sozusagen den ganzen Kongress auch einfach in eins Komuna zubringen könnte und dann trotzdem noch nicht fertig wäre im Sinne von jedes Projekt gesehen zu haben, was da...
Ich glaube deswegen kommen wir auch immer wieder zurück, weil wir halt nie fertig sind.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Kurz ein Element, was auch noch eben im Komuna Platz hat, ist eben der Info-Laden. Und das ist irgendwie vielleicht auch nochmal ein recht zentrales Element, weil was jetzt auch immer wieder gekommen ist, ist sozusagen die Frage von Wissenswiedergabe und auch irgendwie Wissenssammlung. Und wir sind halt so ein Ort, also wir sammeln halt Wissen und schauen, dass das wirklich halt Informationen möglichst vielen Menschen möglichst niederschwellig zugänglich gemacht werden. Und das halt in einer relativ Papierform eigentlich, also gar nicht digital. Das ist vielleicht, wir sind auch so ein bisschen wenig digital, sehr analog sozusagen. Aber tatsächlich hat einfach, was wir halt machen als Kollektiv, wir sind halt in verschiedenen Städten europaweit organisiert, ist halt genau diese Ansätze von Selbstorganisierung, diese Ansätze von aktivistischen Strategien, auch von Widerstand, von den verschiedenen Kämpfen halt zusammenzutragen und halt immer mit uns mitzutragen und an andere Orte zu bringen. Und einer dieser Orte, auf denen wir halt aufschlagen, ist halt der CCC, weil wir halt diese Frage von Technologie und wie gemeinsamer Umgang mit Technologie und wie ein guter Umgang mit Technologie aussehen kann, halt für sehr wichtig befinden. Und weil wir auch alle mit Technologie irgendwie arbeiten, was ja irgendwie Gesellschafts jetzt nicht mehr in eine Situation kommen wird, wo es ohne Technologie läuft, sondern einfach die Frage ist, wie kann die gestaltet werden? Genau, und wir bringen uns da halt auch ein. Also wir sind dann halt auch Teil von eins Kommune und haben halt diesen Anlaufpunkt, wo halt Leute gerne vorbeikommen können, selber Material bringen können. Wir tragen das weiter und sich Material holen können. Und das ist dann halt in verschiedensten Formen. Das sind Scenes, das sind Bücher, also viel sozusagen inoffizielle Literatur, das sind Sticker, das sind Plakate, das ist auch eine Datenbank von Materialien, die es genauso bei uns dann halt gibt. Ja, und da laden wir halt auch alle ein, sozusagen ihre Content, ihre Informationen einzubringen und das halt zu teilen, weil halt irgendwie Wissensteilen und Informationen weitertragen und diese Konzepte, die es halt gibt, an andere weitergeben, ist halt sehr wichtig.
Ja, die Couch dazwischen. Wenn ich vielleicht kurz auf all das eingehen darf, ich glaube, ich hatte gestern ein Gespräch, wo mir noch mal aufgegangen ist, was hat irgendwie so ein krasser Unterschied, also was bei Einskommunas so anders ist. Es sind nicht Tische, an denen die Leute sind und für sich arbeiten und du gehst ihnen hin, sondern eigentlich sind wir alles Kollektive und die Gesamtstruktur ist so aufgebaut, dass sie halt eben zur Verfügung steht und gekommen werden kann.
Also du gehst in so einen Raum rein und trittst dann ein Gespräch mit Menschen und da sitzt doch niemand hinter einem Tisch, sondern das ist eher so ein gemeinsamer Platz, wo du dich halt dazusetzen kannst.
Oder dich einbuchen kannst mit irgendwelchen Workshops, also das ist ja auch mega offen, das kann ja jede Person machen und da gibt es auch kein, also ich denke mal gegen faschistische Workshops würden wir uns jetzt wehren, aber ansonsten gibt es ja keine Regelungen, wer wo was machen kann, sondern es ist halt ein Möglichkeitsraum.
Man muss auch den Einskommuner gar nicht verlassen, weil dann ist ein Tag vorbei, weil den ganzen Tag in der Kommunikation mit so vielen Menschen war es, aus den verschiedensten Städten, über verschiedenste aktivistische Formen, über verschiedenste Sachen, die sie machen, dass du halt schon eigentlich super fit bist nach einem ganzen Tag und dann halt erst die Forte oder die Halle wieder verlässt, um was Neues wieder aufnehmen zu können einfach, weil das so viel gesellschaftstheoretischen, alternativen Input auch beinhaltet. Also allein schon, dass zum Beispiel die Hambi-Leute da irgendwie einen Baum oder einen Kletterpoint simuliert haben, was für die Kinder auch super wichtig und super toll ist, halt diesen alternativen Gesellschaftsentwurf, deine Naturrettung halt auch kennenzulernen. Das ist einwandfrei. Also wo finden wir das sonst?
Ich finde es total spannend, dass bei den ersten beiden Sachen, die wir jetzt hier hatten, fand ich es wichtig, den digitalen Anknüpfungspunkt zu nennen. Aber hier würde ich echt sagen, geht mal vorbei. Also hier auf dem Kongress, aber trotzdem noch die Frage, trotzdem, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, ihr seid gar nicht so digital. Gibt es die Intergalactic Domain Exhibition auch online? Aber gibt es sozusagen, gibt es ein Tor in die Hölle, ein Tor in die Pads? Wie heißt der?
Hashtag Comuna Doppelpunkt, ganz viele verschiedene Server. Aber ich glaube, er ist auch über den Matrix Server erreichbar.
Ihr habt keine Website?
Nein, tatsächlich ist es halt einfach, die Initiativen stehen für sich und wir sind beim Kongress halt zusammen.
Ach so, ich hatte verstanden, das sind verschiedene Städte auch.
Es sind Leute aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Städten. Es sind Leute aus Vilnius, es sind Leute aus Wien, es sind Leute aus Hamburg, aus Berlin, aus...
München...
.München, aus... keine Ahnung.
Dann würde ich sagen, besucht die 1 Comuna, wo ihr sie findet. Und an dieser Stelle würde ich erst mal sagen, vielen Dank. Danke schön.
Heute findet kein Rave statt.
Heute findet kein Rave statt. So was. So, dann haben wir noch ein letztes Thema, einen letzten Beitrag. Und da geht es um Flipdots. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt. Da kommt jemand. Hallo, guten Tag. Bitte einfach am liebsten mich setzen hier hin. Das hat sich bewährt. Und jetzt ist jemand da, der etwas mitgebracht hat. Darf ich die Hardware anfassen?
Ja, die kannst du auf jeden Fall anfassen. Die kannst du auch ein bisschen auseinanderlegen. Ich habe hier mal so ein einzelnes Panel mitgebracht. Das macht es vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher.
Hi, wer bist du? Hi, Flippke. Du hast mir ein einzelnes Panel mitgebracht. Das setzt voraus, es gibt etwas, aus dem dieses Panel ein Bestandteil eines Ganzen ist?
Das ist richtig.
Was ist das Ganze?
Das Ganze ist ein Anzeiger, wo fünf Stück solcher Dinger drin sitzen. Und das ist in einer Tram montiert gewesen.
Also ich habe hier etwas in der Hand. Das hat Rechtecke, davon sind viele schwarz, eine wenige gelb. Es sieht aus wie eine Anzeigetafel, würde ich sagen. Ein einziges Rechteck ist ungefähr ein Zentimeter groß, Quadratzentimeter groß. Und da drin sind Spulen?
Genau, das ist ein elektromechanisches Display. Die sind vorne in den Trams drin gewesen und an den Seiten und haben ein Zugziel angezeigt. Wenn du das mal umdrehst, sollte da auch noch eine Jahreszahl draufstehen.
Hier steht quasi Linie 16, Messegelände.
Das würde da nicht draufstehen, weil sie aus Berlin kommen. Die sind von der BVG tatsächlich. Wenn du mal ein bisschen an der Kunstinstallation vorbeiläufst unter dem UV-Licht, kannst du tatsächlich auch noch...
Schub, schub, wir sind auf dem Kongress. Es gibt ja eine Kunstinstallation, die aus ehemaligen Anzeigetafeln der BVG entstanden ist.
Genau.
Du hast mir gesagt, ich soll eine Jahreszahl suchen. Ich guck mal, ich finde hier Dinge, die aussehen wie... 1530 wird es wahrscheinlich nicht gewesen sein.
Vermutlich nicht.
Ich bin überfordert, ich finde keine Jahreszahl, die eine sinnvolle Jahreszahl ist.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt auch ein schlechtes Modul mitgebracht, wo keine Jahreszahl draufsteht. Ich kann auch mal schauen. Es ist nicht durch die Qualitätskontrolle gelaufen.
Ein Modul ohne Jahreszahl, wie konnte das passieren? Aber apropos Jahreszahl, kehren wir zu den Anfängen zurück. Wie kommst du dazu, Anzeigetafeln von der BVG zu haben?
Ich wollte schon immer mal so Flipdots haben. Und dann hab ich diverse Anliegen.
Okay, Entschuldigung, ich muss schon wieder eine brechen. Kannst du kurz erklären, was ein Flipdot ist?
Ja, das ist das Ding, was wir uns hier gerade angeschaut haben.
Ein Flipdot ist sozusagen eines von diesen einzelnen Vier-Ecken? Oder Quadraten?
Ich würde die gesamte Technologie, die wir jetzt hier auf dem Tisch liegen haben, als Flipdot.
Aber das funktioniert so, das sind quasi kleine Plastekvadrate. Und die werden mechanisch umgeschaltet.
Genau, also wenn man sich das ganz genau anschaut, ist da drinnen noch so ein kleiner Magnet. Und wenn man das jetzt hier versucht, irgendwie so umzukippen, dann kippt das auch von alleine wieder zurück. Das heißt, das kann man nicht auch so runter machen. Das sind so kleine Plättchen. Die kippen dann so hin und her.
Na ja, und wenn sie aufgeklappt sind, sind sie gelb, und wenn sie zugeklappt sind, sind sie schwarz?
Ist das richtig?
Und du wolltest schon immer mal damit spielen? Wie kommt man dann so Zeug ran?
Ja, das fragen mich tatsächlich alle Leute. Wo hast du die her? Gibt es davon noch welche? Ja, ich hab tatsächlich sehr viele ÖPNV-Anbieter mal so angeschrieben und die gefragt, sag mal, habt ihr Flipdots? So auch bei der BVG, da einfach mal angerufen, Flipdots, was ist denn das?
Warte mal, das sind immer so die kleinen Details, die einfach mal angerufen, wen ruft man denn da an? Die zentrale Auskunftsnummer für den Fahrplan oder?
Das ist schon so lange her, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Also ich hatte da irgendeine Rufnummer von der BVG. Einfach mal angerufen, die dann so, ja, Flipdots, was ist denn das? Ah, okay, ja, da wenden sie sich mal irgendwie hier an die Instandhaltung. Das hab ich dann gemacht, dann kam dann irgendwann ein Anruf zurück. Ja, können sie haben. Und dann hab ich erst mal so... Ja, tatsächlich.
Kommen sie vorbei, holen sie ab oder wie lief es?
Genau, genau, so lief das. Ich hab sie dann tatsächlich per ÖPNV abgeholt, ein bisschen unterschätzt, wie schwer die Dinger tatsächlich sind.
Ich muss also für Baselinteressierte nicht unwichtige Fragen stellen. Die haben dir die einfach so gegeben oder du musstest die kaufen?
Ich habe sie gekauft, tatsächlich.
Für relevant Geld oder für... Wir nehmen einen symbolischen Betrag, weil es eher das Zeug ist, das wir wegwerfen wollen.
Na ja, also es kam dann halt so die Frage, was bezahle ich jetzt dafür? Was können sie bezahlen? Ja, das war damals aus dem studentischen Club heraus, den ich gemacht habe. Da hat man sich dann auf einen sehr geringen Betrag geeinigt. Dann hat man mir die in die Hand gedrückt. Was ein bisschen schwierig war, die können die nicht einfach so an Privatleute verkaufen, weil man dann halt sofort mit Haftung und so weiter mit drin ist. Das heißt, das war ein B2B-Verkauf.
Wenn die das als Privatperson verkauft hätten, hätten sie haften müssen, wenn dir das Ding auf die Füße fällt?
Nee, da sind ja einige auch kaputt. Dann hätten sie mir halt die Kaputten auch noch so austauschen. Also ich bin da nicht so 100 Prozent bewandert. Jedenfalls wollten sie mir das Ganze nur B2B verkaufen. Das war kein Thema.
Du hast da so eine Firma gegründet.
Ich bin ohnehin schon da ein bisschen länger als Freelancer in der IT unterwegs. Jedenfalls habe ich die Dinger dann gekauft. Erstmal zwei so große Anzeige. Und das ging dann so ein bisschen mit zum Selbststudium der Elektrotechnik einher. Und die Dinger dann reverse-ingeniert tatsächlich.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen.
Wenn man das Ding umdreht, dann ist ja hinten dran, sind Dinge, die kann ich als Leier, als Mikrochips identifizieren. Und da sind auch Dinge, die kann ich als Steckbleis identifizieren.
Das ist korrekt.
Da kann man einen Breitbandkabel anschließen. Also nicht Breitband im Sinne von Internet, sondern eines von diesen breiten Kabeln, wo man früher Festplatten computerfest gesteckt hat.
Das ist sehr IDI-ähnlich tatsächlich.
Gibt es da eine Programmiersprache, eine Schnittstelle?
Ja, also du siehst hier hinten drauf so zwei Transistor-Reiten. Das ist für jede Spalte, da sind so zwei Transistoren drauf. Und das sind letzten Endes die Spaltentreiber. Was die machen ist, die treiben mir die gesamte Spalte entweder gegen Ground oder gegen VCC, also plus 12 Volt in dem Fall. Und alles, was ich dann noch zur Verfügung stellen muss, sind dann halt die Zeilentreiber. Die Spaltentreiber sind hinten drauf. Und da schieb ich dann so einen Pixel-Takt rein. Und ich dampf jetzt gerade zwei Jahre.
Du redest jetzt aber in einer Sprache, die ich trotzdem nicht verstehe. Lass mich Fragen stellen. Also diese Dinger klappen um, wenn man Strom anlegt. Wenn du Strom anlegst, werden sie gelb.
Das kommt darauf an, in welche Richtung da der Strom fließt, ob sie dann gelb oder schwarz werden. Und es ist auch gar nicht mal so wenig Strom, den man da drauf geben muss. Also für die gesamte Wand, die da hier auf dem Congress steht, sind das tatsächlich 400 Ampere bei 12 Volt. Die hat mehr Leistung, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß, was sich da in Kühlschränken... Das C3 Power Top hat mir da so ein cooles Dashboard gebastelt, wie man sehen kann, wie viel Strom die ganze Installation verbraucht. Das kann man sich auch online anschauen, c3power.top. Das sind so 3 bis 4 kW, die da so durchgehen. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel, aber auf 12 Volt schon relativ viel Strom.
Diese Pixel musst du einzeln ansteuern?
Ich steuere das ganze Ding tatsächlich spaltenweise an, was auch erklärt, weshalb sich die Panels von oben nach unten updaten.
Du sagst immer Spalte gelb oder schwarz. Und dann machst du dasselbe für die rein und dadurch ergibt sich dann das Bild?
Nein, ich cleare zuerst die gesamte Spalte. Das heißt, ich setze die auf schwarz. Und im nächsten Takt übertrage ich dann über dieses breite Kabel, was da oben drauf geht, dann die Informationen, die Pixel-Daten so an die Spalte. Sodass ich eine gesamte Spalte auf einmal setzen kann.
Aber eine Spalte heißt, du sagst, für eine Spalte Pixel 1 schwarz, Pixel 2 weiß und so weiter und so fort. Dann gehst du einmal alle Spalten durch.
Genau, eine Spalte hat 16 Pixel und ich habe 115 Spalten pro Display. Das macht so auf die gesamte Installation, die ich da jetzt gerade in Betrieb habe, 576 x 230 Pixel, die ich darauf darstellen kann.
Und du kannst immer nur eine Spalte gleichzeitig beschicken?
Da ich da sehr viele Panels habe, also sehr viele so große.
Du kannst auf einem Panel immer nur eine Spalte gleichzeitig beschicken. Aber du kannst auf mehreren Panels jeweils eine Spalte beschicken.
Sodass ich halt insgesamt irgendwie so auf vier Frames in der Sekunde komme.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage, das hätte ich gewesen. Also ein moderner Monitor hat so mindestens 60 Hertz, manchmal 120.
Ja, da geht mehr so der Trend.
Du hast vier.
Ich hab vier.
Okay, was zum Standbilder anzeigen, also hervorragend geeignet. Machst du damit auch eine Animation?
Ja, also da hab ich mich tatsächlich erst ein bisschen schwergetan, weil halt Animationen darauf doch recht schwierig sind. Aber da kann man so ein bisschen mit Motionblur tricksen. Und wenn man dann halt so Bewegungen so ein bisschen blurry darstellt und ein bisschen mit Dizzering arbeitet, dann sieht das tatsächlich ganz cool aus und macht auch so ganz coole Geräusche. Weil das Display macht ja andere Geräusche, wenn irgendwie so viele Pixel so per Dizzering setzt, sieht das anders aus, hört sich das anders an, als wenn du alle einmal so rums auf einmal weiß oder schwarz setzt.
Kannst du Dizzering erklären, oder ist mir der Kopf platzt?
Na ja, die Displays, die ich hier habe, wie du gerade gesehen hast, die können ja nur schwarz oder weiß darstellen. Und damit ich so Halbtöne darstellen kann, könnte ich jetzt entweder den Pixel ganz schnell hin und her kippen lassen. Das würde funktionieren, wenn ich die Ansteuerung anders gestalten würde. Ja, darunter würden die Geräte wahrscheinlich ganz schön leiden. Oder was man auch machen kann, ist, dass ich einfach in einem Kasten von 2x2 Pixel dann halt nur 2 Pixel auf weiß stelle. Sodass halt insgesamt, wenn man Abstand von dem Ganzen nimmt, so der Eindruck von einer zweiten Farbe entsteht.
Also quasi ein Pixel sind vier von diesen Kästchen und die schaltest du dann teilweise um und hast so graue Stufen.
Genau so, genau so tatsächlich.
Musstest du denen noch Technik dazu bauen?
Tatsächlich ja. Also diese gesamten Anzeiger kommen mit einem uralten Mainboard daher. Da sitzt noch so ein richtig alter, fetter EEPROM tatsächlich drin. Also so ein steinalter Speicher, wo noch so Grafiken, Symbole und Zeichensätze von der BVG drinne waren, um halt irgendwie dann so anzuzeigen M8 nach sonst wohin. Und die habe ich allerdings tatsächlich alle rausgeworfen und dafür habe ich dann eine eigene Platine entwickelt.
Hast du einen Backup gemacht?
Natürlich. Das gesamte Projekt ist Open Source, also die Hardware ist dokumentiert. Ich habe die Platine, die wir uns jetzt hier gerade angeschaut haben, die da hinten draufhuckepackt ist, die ist dokumentiert.
Aber ist die dokumentiert im Sinne von, du hast die auseinandergenommen und dann dokumentiert oder hast du die selber gebaut?
Nee, die habe ich auseinandergenommen, um zu verstehen, wie das Ding funktioniert. Und dann habe ich sie in einem Schaltplantool dokumentiert, wie sie funktioniert, damit andere Leute, denen ich so ein Ding in die Hand drücke, auch wissen, wie man irgendwie da auch eigene Dinge verbasten kann. Und dann habe ich noch ein eigenes Mainboard dafür gebaut. Das ist eine eigene Ansteuerungsplatine. Da sind dann die Zeiltreiber drin. Und was die dann letzten Endes machen, davon habe ich dann für die 96 Stück in meiner Wand jeweils eine Platine. Und die sind über einen Datenbus miteinander verbunden, sodass ich von einem Hauptsteuerungcomputer aus die gesamte Kunstinstallation steuern kann.
Du hast gerade 96 Platinen gesagt?
Da waren tatsächlich ein paar manuelle Tasks bei dem Löten der Platine. Aber das waren nur sehr große Parts tatsächlich. Was mein Prototyping angeht, bin ich dazu übergegangen, die Platinen in China fertigen zu lassen. Und die bekommt man dort auch fertig bestückt zurückgeliefert. Jetzt warte ich gerade noch auf eine schnelle Express-Lieferung von dem Leiterplattenfertiger, damit ich noch ein paar verbliebene Panels, die gerade nicht funktionieren, in Betrieb nehmen kann. Aber da schafft es DRL tatsächlich seit drei Tagen. Sie haben es dreimal probiert, hier auf die Messe zu liefern, aber sie kriegen es nicht hin. Also DRL Express ist hier irgendwie problematisch auf dem Messegelände.
Die interne Post, die auf dem Kongress funktioniert, ist herzufällig, soll das jetzt da hin liefern lassen?
Ja, das hat tatsächlich sehr gut funktioniert. Da habe ich auch bereits ein Paket erhalten, das war wesentlich schneller da. Diese Lieferung aus China, die jetzt irgendwie schon seit fünf Tagen in Leipzig ist, das ist in der gleichen Stadt tatsächlich.
Hast du denn am Ende dir jetzt ein Tool gebaut oder geklickt durch ein Software, wo du drin malen kannst? Oder programmierst du deine Animation, ich sage mal, von Hand, indem du da Muster in Tabellen einträgst?
Aktuell ist die Software so gebaut, dass ich ein Tool habe, wo ich eine Abfolge von Bildern reinwerfen kann. Und aus diesen Bildern berechne ich mir dann eine Abfolge von Befehlen vorab, die ich mir dann auf die Disk speichere und die ich dann später in das Programm, was die Kunstinsulation ansteuert, reinladen kann, weil das nicht schnell genug wäre, das on the fly zu berechnen. Die Software ist recht langsam tatsächlich für den Steuerungskomputer. Ich habe tatsächlich mehr Zeit auf die Entwicklung der Firmware verbracht, damit ich halt, weil Firmware, die kannst du halt nicht so schnell austauschen, wie eine Software auf dem Steuerungs, auf dem Hauptcomputer, die kannst du halt ganz schnell austauschen. Dann merkst du halt scheiße, die Firmware hat irgendwie einen Bug oder da kann man irgendwie, wenn die Firmware im Moment Fehler hat, kannst du auch irgendwie die Boards durchbrennen lassen oder so was. Dann will man halt da irgendwie mehr Aufwand reinstecken. Und das ist halt jetzt so die Firma in einem Zustand, wo man halt, egal was man im Datenbus reingibt, das Ding brennt nicht durch. Und ja, die Firma dafür ist auch dokumentiert online. Die hat so, ja, verschiedene unterschiedliche Befehle, die man denn senden kann. Das heißt, ich sage irgendwie zu einem Panel, hier hast du einen Framebuffer, stell den mal da. Und was man auch machen kann, ist, ich kann sagen, wie schnell er das Display updaten soll. Das heißt, man kann mit unterschiedlichen Intervallen arbeiten, um mit dem ganzen Ding zu musizieren.
Ich hatte das vorher kurz als Frage im Kopf, aber das machst du tatsächlich auch. Also ich halte mal fest, du musst dafür löten können, Elektrotechnik programmieren, obviously. Du musst Ahnung von Musik haben und Animationen.
Bist du jetzt fertig?
Das mit der Ahnung von der Musik, das habe ich dann tatsächlich an Leute, die sich mit so was auskennen, ausgelagert. Genauso, was Produktionen von einem Video, von dieser Installation angeht. Aber insgesamt würde ich behaupten, dass dieses Flip-Dot-Projekt damit dann auch durchgespielt ist. Ich selber gebe die Installation hier nach ab, sehr wahrscheinlich an ein Kunstmuseum. Die werden dann so Richtung Karlsruhe gehen tatsächlich.
Was ich mich frage bei so einem großen Projekt, ich stelle mir immer vor, wenn man sozusagen bildende Kunst macht, also keine Ahnung, jemand, der eine Holzkultur geschnitzt hat, der hat dann das Werk seiner eigenen Hände vor sich und kann das dann irgendwo hinstellen, ist das auch so ein Gefühl? Weil ich habe bei allem, was irgendwie mit Digitalität zu tun hat, immer so diesen Verdacht von, das muss man dann irgendwie weiterverwenden können. Und das ist für dich jetzt einfach fertig.
Ja, es ist für mich fertig und das ist tatsächlich auch ein ganz schönes Gefühl, wenn man irgendwie so lange an so einem Projekt rumtüftelt, dann hinterher davor stehen zu können. Und was mich tatsächlich auch immer sehr freut, wenn Leute dann da rangehen und irgendwie hat jeder auch so dieses Bedürfnis, das Ding anzufassen, um zu verstehen, wie es funktioniert. Also das sind tatsächlich so Momente, wo man sich dann durchaus sehr freut. Für mich ist das Projekt dann tatsächlich auch so damit durch. Und ich denke mal, dass wenn das dann da in Karlsruhe irgendwo landet, dass ich dann da auch nochmal vorbeidüse und denen da noch irgendwie helfe und irgendwie gucke und vielleicht dann noch das ein oder andere, was jetzt hier auf dem Kongress aufgrund der Zeitknappheit irgendwie nicht mehr geklappt hat, da noch realisiere. Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, ist das durchgespielt. Dann geht es weiter an andere Projekte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was machst du als nächstes?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also ich hätte mal Bock auf eine Lichtinstallation tatsächlich. Aber ich habe da noch gar keine konkreten Ideen.
Na gut, dann fragen wir vielleicht zum nächsten Kongress nochmal nach.
Mal schauen.
Sehr schön. Also man kann das heute und morgen noch hier auf dem Kongress gucken und dann ab wann in Graz Ruhr?
Da habe ich keine Ahnung. Also tatsächlich gar nicht. Ich weiß nur, für mich endet dieses gesamte Projekt erst mal am 5.1. Mit Übergabe der Panels an jemanden.
Anders gefragt, wo kann man dir wie folgen, damit man mitbekommt, wenn du verkündest, dass das jetzt öffentlich zu sehen ist?
Man findet mich unter meinem Namen Flippke auf diversen Medien.
Also F-L-U-E-P-K-I.
Genau, da werde ich das dann auch. Vielleicht auch ganz interessant, den ganzen Code und die Software findet man ebenfalls auf GitLab unter dem Namen. Also gitlab.com. Es gehen aber nicht alle Panels dahin. Einige gehen noch an den Verstehbarenhof zum Beispiel. Und noch so ein, zwei andere Leute, die mir sehr geholfen haben bei dem Projekt. Aber ansonsten sind sie tatsächlich alle weg.
Das heißt, wer auch immer das nachmachen will, muss jetzt selber anrufen bei ÖPNV. Ne, da sehe ich aber noch eine Frage. Du hast die Dinger jetzt von der BVG. Ja. Ist das eine Standardtechnologie? Also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt keine Ahnung in Hamburg anrufe und die zufälligerweise auch so die Dinger rumliegen habe, dann ist die Chance groß, dass ich mit deinem Code was anfangen kann? Oder gibt es da irgendwie so viele Produkte, wie es öffentliche Nahverkehrsbetriebe gibt?
Da bin ich tatsächlich nicht so gut informiert. Also ich hab mich natürlich auch mit anderen Leuten unterhalten, die Flipdots machen. Da gibt es diverseste Ansteuerungen. Es gibt welche, die sind sehr viel eleganter auf einer technischen Ebene als das, was die BVG hier im Einsatz hat. Es gibt auch welche, so von Brose etwas, das ist wesentlich weniger elegant, wo man nur so einen Pixel at a time setzen kann. Und irgendwie dann so ein 60-Pin-Interface dazu hat. Hier sind es glücklicherweise nur 34, um irgendwie 230 Pixel zu steuern. Ja, also die BVG hat, soweit ich weiß, keine mehr. Also ich hab denen jetzt noch die Letzten, um hier kaputte Panels austauschen zu können, aus den Fingern geleuert tatsächlich. Fun Fact übrigens, die Idee war eigentlich, weil mich halt so viele Leute gefragt haben, wo hast du die her? Ich will auch irgendwie Flipdots haben. Also die Idee, okay, ich will jetzt mal irgendwie unters Volk werfen, so an Hacker-Spaces verteilen und an Hacker-Innen verteilen. Okay, wie macht man das dann irgendwie mit der Logistik? Und war halt so die Überlegung, das ist ganz schön teuer, die mit DIL zu verschicken. Also schlepp ich die einfach mal an zum Kongress, mach einfach mal so eine Batch-Order. Und dann, ja gut, 100 Flipdots am Kongress, da kann man auch irgendwie was mitmachen. Und dann ist daraus diese Kunstinstallation entstanden und eigentlich wollte ich die dann tatsächlich noch an einzelne Hacker, die in die Hand drücken, so zum Selbstkostenpreis. Und dann kam halt jemand vorbei und hat halt gesagt, Shut up and take my money, ich nehme hier einmal den ganzen Ladennetz, so sinngemäß. Ich mach damit jetzt keinen Gewinn, aber halt ist halt sehr viel stressreicher, dass irgendwie alles einem dann in die Hand zu drücken.
Damn, na gut, aber das heißt natürlich, hab ich auch sofort den Puls aus dem Ding zu Hause, wäre ich auch ganz schlecht, gar nicht schlecht. Na gut, aber dann nicht dieses Jahr, vielleicht ein andermal. Flipkipp, vielen Dank, dass du hier warst und uns die Flipdots gezeigt hast. Dankeschön. So. Wir müssen hier bald zum Ende kommen. Ich hatte ja am Anfang versprochen, ich werde jetzt was zur Zukunft des Chaosradios sagen. Wir haben heute kurz in der Redaktion gesprochen und es gibt folgende Idee. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr von Markovketten schon mal gehört habt. Das ist so ein Algorithmus, wo man Text analysieren kann und dann werden automatisch neue Texte daraus geworfen. Wir haben die Idee, jetzt alle alten Chaosradios zu transkribieren und das in so einen Markovketten-Generator reinzuwerfen. Daraus entstehen Texte und die durch Sprachsynthese zu vertonen und dann erscheinen also nächstes Jahr jeden Tag ein neues Chaosradio. Punkt. Nein. Tatsächlich wissen wir es immer noch nicht so genau. Es gibt den festen Vorsatz zu sagen, nächstes Jahr mehr Folgen als dieses Jahr. Dieses Jahr waren es zwei. ich kann auch noch erfreulich berichten, also wir haben eins, Komona hatte erzählt, sie hätten viele tausend Pads. Wir haben für diese Sendung nur eins gehabt. Da sind aber doppelt so viele Themen drin, wie wir jetzt gerade auf die Bühne gebracht haben und bei den anderen haben wir gesagt, eigentlich könnte man dazu doch eine Sendung machen. Na mal gucken, was 2020 so bringt. Das war es heute von uns, für euch vom 36. Chaos Communication Congress. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Und mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.